are we
yeah
it's happening
right now
it's a christmas miracle
we didn't have any front credits so i'm
i'm like what
it was just starting
it's like a cold open man it's like snl
credit from later on
it's the
[Laughter]
you're still here welcome ladies and
gentlemen to fat man beyond i'm kevin
smith i am mark bernard hey
ho
we're doing a home show kids uh we did
our last
uh show at uh the cantina for the year
last week
and uh probably good thing because is
cantina open right now bamf man
we are open right now
uh but we canceled our
christmas trip to denver to see the
family so you might be able to hear it
we're in a little
one-bedroom cabin at big bear for
christmas
uh so the baby's crawling up and down
the stairs so i have to mute zoom
mute
mute the broadcast software and then
bamf in so that's why it took forever
but we are open tonight trivia happening
in uh just a couple hours
we uh
we went out and bought um
a whole bunch of tests so everybody
who works at scum and villainy tests
before we open
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
don't get all criticism me uh but uh
normally when we're you know uh i'm home
on a land line mark is uh at the [ __ ]
bathroom in the shining yes and who
knows how good the overlook hotel
[ __ ] wi-fi is unless martin made the
[ __ ] 14.99 a day he might just be
resting on the free internet that allows
you to read twitter and [ __ ]
now i can stream video i can watch my
porn right here from this bathroom there
you go but uh jc you may not you may be
the weak link this week
are you landlined or are you uh are you
wi-fi
i am uh i'm wi-fi but i did a speed test
we should be okay i think
effects
sound good
uh definitely an echo there was an echo
the echo happens when jc unmutes i think
all right so [ __ ] we got old gal for
banff man this week
i'll try to keep my house shut
don't do that you always come in with
the with the good stuff
but there isn't a lot of you know star
wars this week so
you got thoughts on everything you're
also a marvel kid as well
there's no star wars shut up then yeah
really it's so funny because i'm
engaging in a conversation with him he's
already said if i speak
it's going to echo and i'm like but j.c
you're
you like marvel movies don't you he's
like i'm trying to save your stupid ass
[ __ ] show
thoughts on america's force doctrine
from 1943 to 1972.
uh welcome kids we uh
so delighted uh to be able to be with
you tonight and
chit chat about things because oh god
it's been a real hard few days not
talking about uh spider-man no way home
a lot of people have been like where's
your review and stuff um i talked about
a little bit on hollywood babylon this
weekend and one or two people got very
mad at me on twitter where they don't
know i feel like i spoiled anything i
mean i talked about
stuff that the entire world knows at
this point i i'm certainly give no
details and stuff but tonight kids
going deep oh my god like if you've not
seen a spider-man no way home if you've
not seen hawkeye season finale if you've
not watched the matrix
uh
what is it called
uh
rejuvenations
resurrections
um
we then you might want to tune out we i
won't go hard spoilery on
matrix because that's that's a movie
that's going to be so tough to review
other than be like i liked it without
like because it's it's
it
it's it's tough to to not spoil the
whole
[ __ ] movie is a spoiler right like
oh it's tough to have a conversation
about so we won't be spoiling that but
we are gonna spoil the [ __ ]
out of spider-man no way home and for
those people like why why like number
one that's why we gathered number two
it came out like last week like where
are your priorities and stuff uh i hear
you saying i had loved ones in the
hospital or i myself was in the hospital
all right fair enough yes
you squeak through on that but you know
but but come on man it's time to have
the conversation we've been waiting to
have this conversation
for so long since they announced the
movie this is the end of the last movie
when you were like holy [ __ ] just like
the character
um and you were like what are they gonna
do next we finally saw what they did
next so we want to talk about it very
freely very openly
uh like grown-ups and we might get teary
in here so you never can tell never kids
so if you've seen uh if you've not seen
the movie and you don't want it spoiled
for you fair warning
like you know tonight
check
[ __ ] off and then come back and watch us
after you've watched
uh the movie
yeah i don't mean [ __ ] off and go [ __ ]
yourself way but like you know
unless you'd like to go masturbate in
which case by all means go [ __ ] yourself
uh speaking of which masturbation
we must have a sponsor
and one of them must be about balls
probably they must engage somehow um
yeah we don't get to do this show uh
without somebody
uh going like hey man we'll proudly put
our stamp
on uh on that that train wreck of a show
of yours and uh so we got two sponsors
tonight uh sponsored for the top half of
the show
uh ladies and gentlemen of course is
going to be well i don't know where's
the
where's the did you did you text me copy
i texted you uh both
a pdf and a website
oh i see is that file 5768 sorry kids
you're singing backstage now all right
so we start with uh which one you want
to start with i mean let's start with uh
let's start with keeps
done and done man keeps
ladies and gentlemen the good folks at
keeps are sponsoring the top half of the
show tonight
if you're like oh my god i can't wait to
talk about spiderman no way home i can't
wait to talk about
hawkeye well then thank the good folks
at keeps they're bringing it to you
tonight man uh if you want to follow
along
like you did when you were a kid and the
teacher would read and you'd like look
at the book and [ __ ]
you can go to
keeps.com
batman
right now
because that's where you can get a full
month of treatment for free mankeeps.com
fat man k-e-e-p-s
dot com
slash batman what do you get it keeps
you you're gonna get to keep your hair
i'll tell you that much are you looking
at a future of having to wear funny hats
because you're
thinning hair tell the story of how old
you truly are you may dress like a 12
year old but you're [ __ ] 51
then you need keeps kids oh i wish keeps
it existed back when i was a young lad
go look at mall rats when salam bob's
head goes through the changing room door
and gwen's getting changed man i
remember way back then mark my mom saw
the movie and she said oh tiger you're
going bald this what are you talking
about and she said the bald spot in the
back of your head's the size of a
quarter he was a well i'm sure it'll
never get any larger than that and here
i am wearing this
so
don't be me in so many ways but at least
of all that ladies and gentlemen uh you
want to hold on your hair you want to
keep
your care
keeps is the people uh that you want to
talk to tell them about it mark did you
know two out of three guys will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35.
i do i do i i know it every morning it
haunts me like a very
inescapable truth
that is a gold star from mr smith and
the best way to prevent hair loss is to
do something about it while you still
have hair left you can get treated from
home you don't have to go to the
doctor's office for your hair loss
prescription now thanks to keeps you can
visit her doctor online and get hair
loss medication delivered right to your
home to make it easy and deliver your
medication every three months so you can
say goodbye to pharmacy checkout lines
and awkward doctor's visits bye
bye
prevention is key keeps treatments
typically take between four to six
months to see results so it's important
to act fast the sooner you start using
keeps the more hair you'll keep
and find out while keep says find out
why keeps has more five star reviews
than any of its competitors and more
than one hundred thousand men trust
keeps for their hair loss prevention
medication
keeps treatment start at just ten
dollars a month plus for a limited time
you can get your first month free and
how's that
go to keeps.com fat man to receive your
first month of treatment for free that's
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash fatner
ladies and gentlemen those with hair
rule the universe except for jeff bezos
uh so
he's the outlier uh right what you want
to hold on to that hair take it from an
old man who wishes he could go back in
time and just bathe his whole body and
keeps 24 7 like in a matrix type chamber
so that
they look like chewbacca oh
that would be amazing and stuff live
that sasquatch life totally but i didn't
and so i regret it to this day ladies
and gentlemen don't
live the regretful life that i've lived
keep
your goddamn hair keeps it
with keeps
keeps.com fat man ladies and gentlemen
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash fat man uh
they're gonna help you keep your keep
your [ __ ] hair it's all that matters
in this life keep the main event going
let me tell you something more than
dignity
hair
so
keeps.com
fat man k-e-e-p-s dot com fat man we
thank the good folks at keeps for
sponsoring this here half
of uh fat man beyond ladies and
gentlemen keep indeed
uh thanks keeps
yay
uh okay before we get into either
spiderman or hawkeye there's one quick
little news item
and we want to pop don't have a ton of
news this week we were going to just
focus on those two movies but then a
thing showed up that we had to talk
about okay which was
michael keaton after having reprised his
role in the flash movie is now joining
batgirl
as bruce wayne and batman
so this to me number one is good news
i'm a big fan of michael keaton as
batman
i was a big fan of ben affleck as batman
as well but as we just saw well recently
uh in an interview ben was like i'm not
i'm not gonna do ip movies anymore so
ben has made it very clear for a number
of years now that he's
done playing batman it's not that warner
brothers is done with him he's
he's done with them
so they couldn't use
ben as the batman
for this new batgirl movie
so at that point you're already you know
doing michael keaton batman and flash
seems to make sense and you know i've
i i assumed michael keaton
was as beloved as you know for every
generation as he is to to mine but some
folks online uh you know i saw on
twitter
uh were very angry about about that but
angry at the wrong persons because like
it's not this ain't like a case of
warner brothers
you know screwing the pooch or something
that like the the person they would like
to keep playing batman just is not
doesn't seem interested in playing
batman at all anymore
and has made that kind of clear for for
a red hot minute now
so in lieu of ben
who else are you gonna do
like cr
bring on a brand new batman start that i
mean obviously matt reeves is doing a
very separate from the
dc eu movies uh version of batman so you
can't get him so it kind of makes sense
you need a veteran an older guy if
you're going to do this batman beyond
version of batgirl where you know she's
kind of the terry mcginnis and training
and and he's the you know grizzled old
vet or something like that
but i you know i i co-signed it because
that was my batman that was our batman i
mean this adam west was my first batman
but
michael keaton was a wonderful batman
and i see it's crazy on is to see people
on twitter
going after that decision and being like
there was one picture i saw
where somebody was like michael keaton's
batmobile and it was the walker that my
mom was using
so i was very
very familiar with that walker um you
know i mean look [ __ ] make me i i
would love to be
uh the old man that michael keaton is
because was he like [ __ ] 70 and dudes
in incredible shape he still fits in the
[ __ ] bat suit um i think it's a cool
choice but you know again the internet
this year has spent a lot of time
telling me that i don't know [ __ ] so you
know there's a
bunch of people who disagree with me is
thinking that's cool choice but i think
it's
great but you know it's
and again
not really much choice and as
as much as ben is concerned they could
back a money truck up and ben was just
seems completely disinterested in
the in doing that
yeah i mean it's we also seem to be in a
bit of a nostalgia arms race
right if if if no way home is any
indication
there is no version of these things that
you have any attachment to that you will
not see reheated and served back to you
for your pleasure and i know i know
artistically people hate that but
as a pop culture fan for years now like
i'm in my prime like this is amazing
like in a world where we got to see no
way home and and i you know i'm
i love the tom holland spider-man cycle
the other two spider-man cycles
you know i love the second spider-man
movie that sam raimi did but they were
not like they didn't hold my heart like
these new spider-man movies do i know
i'll get crucified online for saying max
like just do spooky booty
i get it but we all have our faves
please let me have it
that all being said i'll talk about it
in my no way home review you know i
found new appreciation for those other
spider-man movies thanks to no way home
that's how good the flick was so
you know when all the spider-man came on
the spoilers when when when you had
their your nostalgia moments in
uh spiderman no way home
you know i was like there for it but
that
didn't that's not my nostalgia you know
what i'm saying like oh i saw those
movies but it wasn't like
that was my childhood like so many
people on twitter were like that's i
grew up with toby toby you know i was a
boy or a girl wearing pajamas of toby's
spiderman and stuff that that wasn't the
case for me but i still loved what they
did
in no way home that being said
this flash movie they're setting up
with michael keaton batman that will
like
you know probably bring tears my eyes
that is my batman i was very emotionally
tied to the 1989 tim burton batman uh so
you know him coming back into the
universe
they're definitely winning the favor of
you know older fans like myself
um it just feels like if they want to do
a spider-man no way home they better
pull in
christian bale as well
and and beg ben to like
jump in there for well then it sounds
like the ben affleck batman is in for in
flash yeah i think that's the one that
they got him for
then i think they i if i'm these cats
i'm like i'm i'm back at a money truck
up to christian bell to be like just
give us two minutes
so we can have our own spider-man no way
home in this flash so weird that we're
having like all the batman's in a flash
movie but
i guess it makes sense they had all the
you know again spoilers kids if you
haven't seen spider-man no way home
three two one they had all the
spider-man's in a spider-man movie that
makes sense they're gonna have all the
batman's in a flash movie that seems
very dc
and i wonder if they're gonna have any
more flashes
yeah exactly what we have seen in the
trailer there's definitely an it looked
like i can't say definitely but that one
image where they had supergirl standing
next to barry there was another berry
different version barry maybe i misread
that picture
uh i mean and then again the tv show
flash has already gotten there by giving
us john wesley ship and giving us
you know barry prime and giving us ezra
miller
you know in in in what was it
that that last big gigantic
crossover event they did their crisis on
infinite earths like we got a piece of
that
but so you got to up that game for the
movie
um i too was uh
was antonio carnevale i said r toby is
your michael keaton be honest kev yeah i
got that that was my point was like i
understand how much people love those
previous incarnations of spider-man
because that was their spider-man that
they grew up with that's how i feel
about
michael keaton
um i won't
i won't uh
to you know devolve into just reading
check because i always get crucified for
doing that as much as i could crucify
for cutting mycroft
um but uh
this dude a.d on in chat said i missed
90s kevin smith
tell you something
i miss 90s kevin smith too my god that
[ __ ] had more power than he
realized like you know took me a decade
or two
into the arts when i was oh you know the
2000s kevin smith to realize oh my god i
really had the world by the string like
i was the flavor of the month that's
crazy so yeah i missed that guy too but
this seems like a negative thing
mark i don't think he was saying it in a
like i missed that guy
i think he was saying that like uh i
don't like this new kevin smith i miss
90s kevin smith probably because he
talked less i hear that quite a bit
online people like oh i like you when
you were silent
i'm like oh that's a
god [ __ ] what an original joke that
is can i write that down that's very
good no
no coward yes
um in any event you know it's you always
have to put out so many [ __ ] caveats
these days just to say you like a thing
but i do like this thing i do like that
michael keaton is going to be the batman
in the batgirl movie that does not make
me upset in fact it makes me happy
mm-hmm
i miss christmas say that it upsets some
people but like again i i i know the guy
who was batman and he's he's been very
clear about how he's
he's he had a great time doing it but
he's done doing that now he wants to do
different things so if you can't have
you know
if you can't be
with the bat you love honey love the bat
you're with or the one you get and
you're getting like
all right for one i'm a-okay with that
outstanding
uh all right should we move on to our
marquee topic for the evening we we
might as well uh unless you want me to
tell a few elvis stories before we jump
in there
i saved a couple but i still there's a
few things i haven't spoken about i
didn't do the jungle room at all mark
um wow i appreciate you giving some
powder drive
in the next couple of episodes
we should give them the spider-man talk
that can't be here but rest assured
stick around long enough there will be
some elvis talk later ooh baby new year
let's uh let's talk about it let's talk
about spider-man no way or you know what
do we do we do the appetizer first then
dive into the meal
you know it but it's it's unclear which
is the appetizer and which is the meal
because hawkeye is the most recent
hawkeye just happened yeah but i feel
like more people like
all right of the let's start with
hawkeye we'll start with hawkeye let's
make him wait and you know why you're
waiting because a.d made a crappy
comment there you go
i'm passing the passing the blame on
there you go now you'll wait for your
spider-man review um let's talk about
hawkeye which i just watched uh today
uh their seasons now i forgot that it
went up like at midnight last night and
i was awake we got this dying dog marty
matt martign that we've been taking care
of and so
she tends to like get up at midnight
and then it's you're on constant care
duty and [ __ ]
so um i i wish i'd remember that i would
have watched it last night but i watched
it with jen uh my wife today and i was
glad i did because she
uh dug it as much as i did i loved the
hawkeye
season finale i thought it was [ __ ]
pure joy i thought it was the best
episode of the whole [ __ ] run and
there was someone on twitter let me see
if i could find it somebody put up a
tweet and i was going to respond to it
but i was like just [ __ ] it i'll do it
on the show
hold on
[Music]
put my blast that's david for this
um
god damn it where is it they they
brought up me
and they brought up uh there it is it's
from uh
glitter ho 9 on twitter yeah i love
glitter hose work
big fan as well uh kevin and pat and
oswald must be feeling like dicks in
capitals
right now
after the hawkeye finale that'll teach
them to disrespect a hero who's brave
enough to do what's right
no matter the cost
now normally when you know people
you know tell me
i'm a dick i'm like well
i just i tend to disagree i like myself
i totally agree with that tweet because
i was so [ __ ] moved by a moment in
the show
and it really flipped my opinion
of hawkeye like as a character as a
character as did i i'm right there with
you
and if it's the line that you're that
i'm thinking of i i i [ __ ] rolled
tears i did this as i was sitting there
watching it because i was like jesus
christ you really broke broke it all
down for me and spoilers if you haven't
seen hawkeye yet there's a moment where
kate bishop
tells
clint barton what
you know the moment she saw him about
the moment she saw him about how she was
inspired jumped off a building that you
can't lie and that [ __ ] kills me
she's like you they were at you you
fought aliens with a with this
stick and a string is that it is that
what the line was yeah something like
that um the stick in a string line
[ __ ] destroyed me where i was like oh
my god like you're right like you know
we all joke about hawkeye and being like
uh the least avenger but it's like
you know
yeah dude doesn't have powers can't
[ __ ] fly it's literally just fighting
people with a stick and a string uh i
thought that was so insanely well
articulated i don't know if they ever
did that in the hawkeye series if that's
a line that they lifted i know they
lifted a bunch from that
matt fraction series but kudos to
whoever came up with that [ __ ] line
man because that really flipped
my opinion to hawkeye i i loved the
season finale uh it was
uh you know they brought in spoilers
again and we're going deep
uh wilson fisk deep into the
marvel universe uh holding the old style
comic cane with the big diamond head on
it and stuff
um at one point they had him in a
hawaiian shirt which was kind of weird
but
um but they brought him in and let him
fight kate bishop and he beat the [ __ ]
out of her until you know she found a
way to beat the [ __ ] out of him
uh that was it was filled with comic
book battles like the season finale um
the swordsman turned out to be not a bad
guy but a
you know kind of okay
he's zorro basically who's yet to find
out that he's zoro essentially um the uh
um seeing
the new black widow
elena um
and that her scene with clint
yeah that was really [ __ ] emotional
too
like where she just beats the [ __ ] out
of him and he takes it and you know
that's her
and he's and he can't give her what she
wants other than like she sacrificed
herself she made a choice she knew her
it was really sweet that he was able to
tell her like she talked about you all
the time and all that [ __ ] even though
it felt a bit retconned to me because
i'm like when we've never seen it i
didn't see it but you know they had
lives outside the movies they did they
kept talking about budapest and we've
never actually seen what happens in
budapest good point man good point
so i found that touching as well well
done uh looks like they're setting up
that echo series fairly well they you
know uh they had her confront
the kingpin in the end uh and then of
course we
pan off them and hear a gunshot leaving
it nice wide open for you know what
happened but he ain't going nowhere they
didn't introduce that character just
take that that quickly um just like they
didn't introduce
you know daredevil
matt murdock rather into spider-man no
way home to just be like ah it's a
little nod for you kids
from what i heard today online on
twitter
the great matt wagner who made mage and
grendel uh matt murdock's going to show
up in in all the disney plush shows
is he going to be this guy now he's
going to be connected
they're going to use them like rosario
like they have rosario in the netflix
shows it sounds like so i guess he shows
up in um
uh what else
i mean she-hulk makes sense yes um
ms
i don't know about secret invasion but
okay sure i think see i think all the tv
shows from what i would look i have read
a piece online and it's
take it with a grain of salt but a lot
of those [ __ ] online pieces turn out
to be right
um
yeah hawkeye insanely well done uh when
they put on the costumes i geeked out
um
you know all of it
like you know her i thought one of my
favorite [ __ ] moment that re i had to
rew other than the stick and stick in a
string line but the one that made me
laugh was
like hawkeye takes a [ __ ] shot and
you know takes out two dudes and the one
guy catches the one arrow and he's like
nice shot [ __ ] hawkeye from a
distance goes yeah no [ __ ]
so wonderful like you know like the best
the greatest marksman in the world the
guy's like nice shot he's like yeah no
[ __ ] that made me [ __ ] laugh it was
amazing though that like i loved how
street level the whole show was like it
is not about big things it's not about
you know world dominating world changing
events
but when you break the rockefeller
christmas tree in half i literally
gasped
they couldn't have done like done that
for real because i buy everything else i
buy like planets getting cut in half i
blind moons like crashing into dudes
faces
but the rockefeller sent a christmas
tree was like my favorite special effect
in a long time
and also like the fact that they just
ended it in [ __ ] 30 rock essentially
yeah
i'm in the tree yeah right there on the
rink and all that [ __ ] uh they missed an
opportunity
to do an snl crossover man like that i
remember when spider they had that
spidey issue where he went he was on
[Laughter]
him in ballousia belushi's on the cover
as a samurai
mri or delicatessen um
yeah man it was uh i i thought you know
i i i thought it finished insanely well
helped that it was an hour long
um it felt like a 10 minute song at the
end though did you watch
the full
the full broadway number hell yeah i
watched all of it this is family well
done that was a guy from red wasn't it
the guy who's like the lead the lead
singer i think so yeah yeah yeah it's
like adam from rent i think that's yeah
and i loved it because it also showed
just how much nobody in the real world
cares about clint barton
because everybody else gets their shine
and it's like and you who've got good
aim and like that's it
you're good too
um and i guess it was what was it mark
this is mark shaman he was the conductor
yeah
he's the guy that did you know the
movie with uh trey and matt the south
park flick
academy award dominates amongst many
other things but yeah it was nice to see
him in there as well
um did you catch the uh agent 19
mockingbird reveal
yes
yes which to me i was not an agent
agents of shield
watcher
so i know there are people with definite
feelings about it because they're like
well that [ __ ] kills off
right the possibility that agents of
shield is in continuity or canon or
whatever
not necessarily but they do seem to kind
of be going out of their way to
not [ __ ] on agents of seal shields but
be like
no
yeah they just take what they like dark
hole we're taking yeah
um the uh but but um you know
mockingbird like in the comics goes way
the [ __ ] back yeah there's also a west
coast avenger right next to hawkeye they
got married in the [ __ ] comics and
stuff so it's actually cute when they
revealed that she was aged 19 i was like
cute he did marry [ __ ] monkey bird
like he did in the comics
but i also understand that you know you
can't make one person happy without
making somebody else unhappy somewhere
and so there's some people that were
like well that's the final nail in the
[ __ ] agents of shield
coffin
and for somebody who invested a lot
in that show
you know
and and felt like well it's tangential
but it's still connected to those movies
um i it seems like to not be so much the
case anymore whereas daredevil
is
here
with kingpin
um
i mean i guess just the two of them but
[ __ ] man i mean
and with
with the echo getting her own show i
mean it sounds like more kingpin
yeah no i uh
i i really really dug it i was surprised
how much i did
um especially in the first couple the
first couple were a little slow but i
dig what they were doing but you know
establishing his sort of
you know
ptsd i guess is not quite the right word
but his his ongoing emotional burden
that he would have to carry throughout
it over natasha over losing his hearing
over his disconnection with his family
all those things and how kate as an
agent for him learning to sort of heal
and reconnect and and not be so isolated
anymore i just i really like that arc
and that story
um and i love the finale because
ultimately the finale was emotional it
was here's how these two people have
each grown you know one into being the
hero that you always wanted to be and
another into being um into finding some
closure
for his natasha issues by getting to
tell her sister exactly what happened
and that he did everything that he could
and i couldn't have won that fight you
know it's like you know natasha as well
as anybody i was never going to beat her
if you had a mindset on something and
that's guilt that he has been carrying
with him since endgame that he could
have done more
and to find that moment for him to
articulate that no i did everything i
could and that's just what it was um and
the sort of hawkeye reclamation project
i appreciate it because i like you was
also like this guy
he gives a [ __ ] about this guy
and then they made a show that made me
give a [ __ ] about that guy you know and
so i i appreciate it for that
um
i have no notes other than to say
that
hawkeye the the the ending of the second
episode is the second and last episode
when you reveal kingpin in that shot in
that photo
um
doesn't mean anything
unless you watched
marvel's daredevil show on netflix it is
literally just a guy in the picture and
the episode ends with this like
dum dum dum
but it doesn't like it it carries no
weight if you don't know and marvel has
for a long time been sort of like the
open door
um it's an open tent where come on in
welcome everybody's welcome you know
there's something for everybody in here
and it's gotten to be a little bit
insular in a way that it hadn't been
before which is if you don't know who
kinkan is then this means nothing to you
you know the the weight of those scenes
getting to see vincent d'onofrio who's
very good
um but is lessened by the fact that you
he has if you don't know he means
nothing to you
and so just
i i find that interesting that marvel is
beginning to you know like when elena
shows up at the bottom of episode four
you're like oh it's you later unless you
didn't see black widow in which case
it's just a person
like
and so the the reliance on us knowing
the content
to add dramatic heft is an interesting
choice to me
um not bad not good just interesting but
no i really i really really dug it or
all the hawkeye
yeah
they really i mean again if you could
not only entertain me for the episodes
but in the end flip me on the character
in general where i'm like holy [ __ ] this
guy's actually the batman of this group
like he's the only god
who literally [ __ ] walks beside
giants and like earned his place at the
table so i was delighted by that um you
know that's it's one thing to have
marvel make an entertaining show they
know how to do that to make a show that
makes me go like well aren't i a [ __ ]
dick in all caps says that person
tweeted
absolutely the uh just uh to um answer
some questions for the folks in chat
people like there could be two
mockingbirds yeah absolutely nobody's
saying i'm not saying there's not two
mockingbirds in fact i think earlier if
you rewind the tape i said
something to the effect of like
could be one replaced by another
whatever the [ __ ] but yes nobody's
saying that
in you know especially in a world of
multiverse there's plenty of [ __ ]
mockingbirds out there and stuff so that
doesn't necessarily negate
uh the agents of shield
one but
but
people get very sensitive about their
shows mark
you know i don't know i couldn't have
seen that coming
uh the other question a lot of people
are baffled by the fact that you're in
your bathroom i too thought that mom
had a really hot hard deco bathroom in
his house that i'd never seen before but
if you look very closely kids it's a
very familiar bathroom yeah see that
lady in the tub behind mark one that's
gonna get up move that curtain and come
at him and [ __ ] hug him like a little
kid on a big wheel that's right
i'm starting a new sitcom 237.
uh mark is in the shining tonight kids
that's why
a lot of people were like is mark
sitting on the toilet
ready to crap all over stuff you love uh
that dan guy in chat said the true hero
of hawkeye is the owl how [ __ ] up was
that moment man like it was keeping the
cows in the tree like it was last
christmas in rockefeller center but they
let the owl pick up the [ __ ] shrunk
truck and take it away
i i half expected him to say oh hey
buddy and have the album go whoo
they missed it one more draft who got
there
okay
listen i want to just give one more
bouquet of roses to florence pugh
because her performance as elena is one
of my favorite things there's always
this delight there's always this little
bit of like i'm gonna go kill clint
barton but first let's have some mac and
cheese i made the mac and cheese it's
going to go to waste if you don't eat
this mac and cheese and just if the fun
like big when kate and elena have the
big fight it's like i really like when
you flipped over the tables like i know
but then you kicked me in the ribs
nothing really hurts like i'm sorry but
i have to go kill clint but you're
coming along really well like i just
love that
sort of you know older cousin why do why
do all the russian characters use her
full name they're all like kate bishop
like the tracksuit mafia and elena
they're all they just can't call her
kate they just they have their full name
kate the bishop
kid
kenny parquet's sister used to call me
kevin smith my full name to my face all
the time like
calvin smith and like
are there other kevin's you could just
say yeah
i have to use my government name and
everything jeez
but to be fair her brother's name was
kevin horvath maybe that's why she
called me kevin smith there were two
kevin's oh my god all the time i've been
like
man that was silly but it was necessary
i appreciate you solving that no no no
no no wait that's kevin horvath i'm
confusing things anyway back to you
sorry all right i guess we did not solve
a four-year-old mystery we got it
um once again uh mark uh this is not a
criticism of hawkeye but uh
i don't know if everybody noticed this
but uh mephisto didn't show up in this
[ __ ] show either
no we are we are like oh for four
they're really gonna make you wait man
before they pull that [ __ ] character
out there was a chance i remember online
a bunch of people were speculating like
well [ __ ] man maybe uh mephisto
is gonna be the bad guy in no way home
and [ __ ] and uh having seen it spoilers
still not mephisto
they're gonna make you beg to get
mephistoed man they're gonna be like
we're gonna we're gonna make you work
for it man it is too
too easy and convenient to throw
mephisto out there they got so many
characters they're like we'll get to
mephisto maybe
yes if it's in our purview if we decide
if we feel like it
um but no i really dug it i really dug
it and at the end of this episode
i figured maybe we would go through our
mcu 2021 rankings because there were
nine mcu things this year
nine
nine time
huge [ __ ] year for the mcu and so i'm
not ready yet all we got to do to get
there is talk about spider-man right
that's about it
i'm not ready yet to do a a best of 2021
yet list incomplete because there's
still a [ __ ] ton of stuff that i got to
catch up with
and so i figured my christmas break is
going to be spent watching and and
reviewing some of those things
so yeah top of the year we'll get into
what we loved from the year before but
tonight i figured we could do that
nine things man it was a great marvel
rich year whereas last year there were
like no things right no things uh i will
i will alphabetically i'll go through
them and then we can figure out what the
rankings are later
black widow came out this year
uh eternals [ __ ] winner soldier
um
this year loki one division what if
hawkeye spiderman and chungchi
god man that's all the [ __ ] marvel
this year that's a ton of marvel
um so yeah well i will rank them by the
after on the back end of no way home
um
speaking of no way home let's dive into
it
we me and mark and jc
and uh a bunch of cats uh nate who does
our
artwork for the show nate gonzalez and
the artwork for the show this week is
gorgeous as per always
um my wife came with us which is [ __ ]
rare she's now into marvel enough to be
like i'll go to that thing
uh we all went to the 40x uh offices
down the street and watched
um
uh spiderman no way home and what was it
screenx a
screenx yeah it's like basically um
periodically throughout the movie you
know you got the screen dead ahead of
you but then periodically throughout the
movie the
the project the walls come to life and
the movie projects onto the walls to the
side so you're surrounded
by the bullets incredible process by
which they lengthen the frame so at one
point as we were seeing
the villains the
i mean spoilers again there's gonna be
lots of [ __ ] spoilers so when it was
on the poster yes we said that would be
supposed to support so when when people
were you know
wizard of ozin at the end and going home
there's a shot that panned and this one
left and that one left
in screen x they were on the sides like
it was even more impressive we were
surrounded by
by the villains who were even off camera
it was pretty is pretty impressive
impressive process what they do uh if
you get a chance to see a movie in 40x
screen x absolutely
uh do it um not because they gave us a
free screening which was awesome but
it's a fantastic presentation of movies
like this i wouldn't go see
you know clerks 3
in
x
or anything like that but but like uh
these flicks oh heavens yes we saw
ghostbusters and screen x ghostbusters
and then uh we just saw spiderman no way
home so we all went on it was thursday
and they told us uh like based on the
time it was we watched it at what like
one two three or something like that
yeah three o'clock in the afternoon
so that meant it was only six on the
east coast so they hadn't even started
the screenings
for
spider-man on the east coast yet so the
guy was like technically
this is the first public screening in
north america that's not a premiere or
something like that
um and there was only like 10 of us in
the theater it was great but thank god
we had bodies together in the theater
this is not a movie look see it any way
you can but it's not really a movie
um that that you should enjoy
alone uh the audience added a dimension
to it um just like you know avengers end
game
what a fun movie that was to be
surrounded by like 200 people and vibing
on that energy and sucking in that
omicron but um
you know just like the
moments oh wow
you know or just better in the
collective experience that's why you
know people invented religion and go to
[ __ ] church man it feels better to be
spiritual as a group if you're all
believing in the same thing and when
you're in a movie you're all believing
the same thing particularly if that
movie rocks the house and this john
watts kid man who's been making these
spider-man movies for the last few years
what a genius like he stuck the landing
beyond stick in the landing man like he
made three
for my money i know there are people
like that ain't spider-man tony stark
helped out too much well they fixed that
at the end of this [ __ ] flick didn't
they
honey these spider-man movies have been
wonderful and this kid is so [ __ ]
talented i can't wait to see his
fantastic four man to say the least but
i'll watch him do anything he's saying
he's just doing a movie
with some like with clooney or something
like that some famous [ __ ] before he
met yeah
fantastic i don't remember what it was
but i remember seeing that announcement
that he was like before i hop into the
you know marvel's first greatest heroes
i'm gonna go do this like actual real
drama thing there's a shot in this movie
at one point that's like a real it's an
uncut [ __ ] single take it feels like
it goes for like a minute two minutes
maybe three or something when uh
you know uh happy's in the doorway in
the very beginning when they first get
back to to amaze apartment
very long uncut take you know like they
don't do that they don't have to do that
in movies like this right
but my man took time out
to make some art not just to make some
commerce like he's like look just
because we're making a pop movie doesn't
mean it can't [ __ ]
have cinematic elements to it [ __ ] like
so i it always impresses me because i'm
like i'm supposed to be a filmmaker and
i don't even think like the people like
somebody like john watts who's like he's
a filmmaker too but like he he makes
movies he's a movie maker for heaven's
sake so i'm a filmmaker uh indeed like
my best
so naturally like
his cinematic language
is
like
incredibly impressive enough to capture
you know mainstream big mainstream gig
like this but he also keeps it artistic
like um
there's a lot of transition he does as i
was watching the movie i was like that's
[ __ ] clever that's clever little
touches that nobody has to do because
like we're all paying to see this movie
anyway it could be one long [ __ ] shot
of his ass xerox over and over again so
long as they you know push details
forward one inch and we'd all be okay
with it but i appreciate like the
filmmaking that that he brings to it not
not just the movie making if that makes
sense and i don't want it to sound
reductive and some [ __ ] websites be
like
smith looks down his nose not in the
least if anything i'm [ __ ] looking up
at this cat i'll tell you right now i'll
never make a movie as entertaining and
enjoyable as spider-man no way at home
um and they earned theirs like over
years of telling a story uh you know not
even this current crew of people telling
the story but as far back as sam raimi
you know when they started selling
spider-man stories back there naturally
it's a big celebration of all things
spider-man and what it means to be peter
parker um not all that different
or or unrelated rather to you know
spider-man into the spider-verse feels
like once they saw that work they were
like oh [ __ ] it let's do ours
and
up the ante by making it incredibly
special as most of us know by now
by bringing in other spider-men
um so this goes beyond just being a
movie right to being a pop cultural
event and even beyond pop cultural just
a cultural event so much so that
it grossed 250 million dollars opening
weekend
in a pandemic is like [ __ ] beyond
impressive but even if we weren't in the
middle of a pandemic even if we weren't
dealing with
uh omicron and stuff like that
that that's a huge [ __ ] number is
what number two of all time or something
only behind end game it's it's the
let's see the third biggest global
opener ever at 600.8 million dollars in
its opening weekend
global um the fourth biggest
internationally unadjusted and the
second biggest domestic where it edged
out infinity war
um
so yeah i mean it's it's massive
everybody went to go see it at a time
when
you know most movies are not doing that
well yeah you know there's a lot of
hand-wringing over something like you
know west side story which opened the
week before to less than rapturous
attendance at the box office and people
like does this mean the end of movie
going and then spider-man opens and
breaking records not pandemic records
but just records records i mean not for
for nothing and this is not
you know love spielberg and i love west
side story but like
you could one could make the argument
that like even though steven spielberg
doing it it was a familiar story that
you know people have seen a movie on it
maybe seen their high school musical
version of it maybe saw a broadway
version of it like
you could have seen many iterations of
west side story and and without leaving
your house to see the new one you can't
see no way home anywhere but a theater
and you know it's it's also like we've
not seen this iteration yes we've seen
spider-man movies before but like
you know now it's malibu stacy with the
new hat they've added things like they
put
dr strange into it and whatnot you know
uh it's so you could see
this was the movie that everyone was
gonna leave their house for if there was
any movie since end game that the world
was going to be like oh my god i i'll
risk everything for that
it was going to be this so the pressure
was on
you know what i'm saying like yeah they
could have just easily been like look
all we have to do is get a couple
spider-mans together and just in the
frame and we'll be good but they
actually gave us
a really uh touching movie
um that wasn't the movie i at least
thought we were getting for the last two
years like i thought they were setting
us up for like he's gonna [ __ ] fight
the sinister six from across all the
spider-man universes and
yeah but it wasn't so much about the
fight
as like how do we save them um which was
so sweet and you know of course it comes
largely from aunt may who plays a very
important role in this movie and says in
a very important line at a certain point
um
but it was so peter parker
to want to save
the bad guys finding out that they'd all
die fighting spider-man
you know click something in them where
it's just like i can't like you know
with aunt maybe and like helping out by
being like you you can't let that happen
peter
um
and then the cost of that decision
that's so [ __ ] classic spider-man you
know the weight of this guy's decisions
that he makes and
you know and he's always trying to do
the right thing and yet sometimes it
falls apart in his [ __ ] lap or in his
face or at the end of his web
so you know in a series of of movies
where uh
he's been criticized for not being the
peter parker that we all know from the
comics who has to build his own web
shooters and
you know he's tony stark jr
um to a lot of people dismissively uh in
this iteration of the character they
were able to tell a story where they
kind of strip they take that to the nth
degree
where he's you know eventually like uh
doing doctor strange like magic in some
sequences
and then
reduce it and
get rid of it all in an almost
uh
you know what was the book that they did
one last day
kind of
reboot retcon
that makes sense within the story
and then gives you
that version of spider-man that people
who didn't like this version of
spider-man have been asking for
one that has no connections
to wealth to everybody people know
there's a spider-man
but they don't know who peter parker is
was such a sweet [ __ ] touch so
bittersweet and i was so glad they spent
the last few minutes of the movie
showing us that world rather than being
like well we'll show you next time and
stuff they let us see like peter go into
the world and see
how life went on
without him in a world where people
didn't even know
he existed
um except for of course
you know if you look closely
she just still got her little venetian
sunflower
the balcony but why like why would she
wear she you know she'll know where she
got it she just knows
that she wants to wear it and stuff and
you can see they're going to try to
bring the characters back together
naturally somewhere down the road but
how [ __ ] emolicious
was that ending i know like there's the
one ending of spider-man 2
you know where she's like who's going to
save you peter parker
and he still has to like walk away
from her at the end of the day i don't
know if that was the first one the
second one i can't remember but
you know the idea of with great power
comes great responsibility and he can't
be happy and stuff like that
this version of that story where like
he's got because he chooses to be her
hero because he chooses
you know the choice at the end
to kind of uh essentially go through
with the spell he was trying to go
through with in the first place
um but knowing now that the whole world
all the people that care about him are
going to forget him and even the other
people and stuff
i thought was so brave and a brave and
bold choice to strip the character back
down in the third movie and then strip
him down so [ __ ] far that they let
him make his own suit
and it's blue as [ __ ]
no he's swinging by the
clint barton memorial christmas tree at
the end of the movie and he's wearing
the blue spandex man and you're just
your heart is filled with [ __ ] joy
but long before we get there
um we have we our story picks up right
where our story left off
uh in uh the last picture man with uh
his identity being spoiled and whatnot
and as we've seen in the trailers uh you
know life is difficult for peter parker
or the whole world knowing who he is and
so he goes to doctor strange and says
hey can you can you make everyone forget
he's like but wait but not mj and wait
not aunt may and ned but wait wait and
then the spell goes wrong and
because of that
the last thing the words were like
anyone who knew peter parker was
spider-man
um covers the spell so you know everyone
will forget except the people who
already knew that peter parker
spider-man so based on that terminology
we get characters who knew that peter
parker
was spider-man from other
iterations
of of the character across the
multiverse but for us the other
spider-man and the other spider-man
movies a premise that they've been
hitting that for a long time most of the
internet knew
um and then they started giving away big
time in in the trailers so that means
you get willem dafoe back his green
goblin and
mercifully john watson's like we're
gonna break that [ __ ] mask as soon as
possible
that you could just work with the
insanely expressive face of of willem
dafoe who like is wonderful
in the flick and is wearing a very
goblin
specific reminiscent costume right down
to the [ __ ] hood and everything
seeing him on the his batwing flyer gun
is very cool um
it allows them to bring back uh the
alfred molina doctor octopus otto
octavius um it allows them to bring back
uh risa fonz who played
the lizard
in the andrew garfield spider-man movies
um jamie foxx playing electro a much
better version of electro who not only
gets to come back but gets retconned
rebooted and and uh and actually gets a
star mask at one point
yeah based on the electricity across his
face and then uh who was the other one
that they brought man
sam man as well what's his face thomas
hayden church i'm a satan church um
you know and and so the whole time
you're like all right so this mysterio's
got to be the last one
because you're like there must be doing
sinister six and that wasn't their aim
that's not the story that they're
they were telling um they're all
captured and
strange as uh basement or whatever [ __ ]
and uh you know that's when peter finds
out that they're all gonna get sent back
to where they came from
because apparently they were all sucked
out of their stories right before
their they perished
uh so they don't have memory of dying or
whatever like
otto octavius is talking about his
machine the power of the sun
in your hands and stuff which was the
plot of spider-man 2.
um and so they figure out you know that
these cats came through this dimensional
rift based on the spell the multiverse
exists
and
doctor strange is going to send them all
back to their universes but when they go
back
their story continues and they're gonna
die fighting spider-man
and so in a conversation with aunt may
who tells him like you know you can't
you gotta try to help these people he
can't like just abandon them like that
and you know she's his conscience
he decides to
try to do the right thing and and
reform and change the villains before
sending them back um to do so he has to
trap doctor strange
which uh
you know he's in the movie a bunch and
then all of a sudden he's not in the
movie for a long time
and then um it's
it's
we get to a place where uh
ned and mj are looking for peter and and
uh you know
ned has gotten a hold of
a sling ring and uh it could do magic in
this movie and
opens a portal dr strange style as
they're like look for you know find
peter parker
and they find the first
not there peter parker but the first of
the other peter parkers they find is
andrew garfield
who
i like appreciated so much more in this
flick i thought he was like of the two
spider-man i liked his spider-man and i
like toby's peter parker
um like you know because i thought
andrew garfield way too hot sexy and and
cool
to be peter parker but he pulled off the
spider-man insanely well um i i went the
other way in this movie i thought he was
like wonderful from from the jump he had
such energy
um it's adorable that they call him
amazing like at one point
he's like you're you're amazing and he
is the amazing spider-man um you know he
references the death of gwen
and does it emotionally you know which
chokes you up even though again i wasn't
like
big into the the other spider-man movies
as much as i am to the marvel cinematic
universe stuff and still that made me
emotional uh and then of course when
they open up another portal they find
another spider-man and that spider-man
is is the youth pastor spider-man
peter parker your friendly neighborhood
spider-man i guess disney just put out
their official titles
uh this week so
in reference because now that the
movie's out they can
talk about the fact that they've got
other spider-man in the movie so they're
referring to toby spider-man as the
friendly neighborhood spider-man or your
friendly neighborhood spider-man and
they're referring to andrew garfield
spider-man as the amazing spider-man
each have their derivations how cool is
that there was i saw a tweet before i
went to see the movie where somebody was
like the world better get ready for the
fact that those spider-men he meets are
going to be mysterio projections
and i was like oh mother [ __ ] if they do
that and they did not they [ __ ] flat
out played it straight man they're like
there's a multiverse there's magic ned's
working a [ __ ] sling ring all the
spider-man's gonna get together and talk
about back pain
um and they're gonna fight all their
villains together uh but while trying to
reform them
all of it was
unexpected and and wonderful uh for my
money the whole time i was
now um uh what eventually uh happens of
course is uh big time spoilers ladies
and gentlemen uh norman osborne seems
like you know he could be reformed he's
uh he's
he's
playing it straight playing a good guy
at first
and then he goblins out flips and and
winds up
killing
a beloved character spoilers again if
you've made it this far
um i'll give you three seconds get the
[ __ ] out three
two
one
so uh in the reverse of the spider-man
lure as most of us know it um
we
peter loses
aunt may as opposed to uncle ben so they
never referenced i thought this is going
to be the movie they were like when ben
died and stuff but
they didn't go for it they kept they
kept the focus on aunt may so aunt may
you know gets hit by
the green goblins glider the back wing
glider and uh
you know she's looks worse for wear and
she's spitting out advice to peter about
how you know she finally says the the
words um oh my god got me so emotional
and it'll get me emotional again in the
theater i was like rolling tears where
she paraphrases she doesn't say with
great power comes great responsibility
she said with great power must come
great responsibility to write that in
there you're like they're gonna kill her
there's no way she lives
after saying that line and then they
reveal that she's bleeding out and stuff
and so you have to watch aunt may die in
his arms and that kid is such a good
actor tom holland remember like when you
know tony stark was dying and he was all
like sad and [ __ ]
this dialed up to the nth degree
really beautiful sad moment in the in
the spider-man universe uh in the marvel
cinematic universe version of spider-man
um wonderfully wonderfully done i
thought and uh then you've got
you know the conundrum of like he wants
revenge [ __ ] trying to help these people
like just
[ __ ] kill him yourself never mind
sending him back and kill get him killed
but
he ain't gonna do that you know he's
gonna be the person that
that aunt may want him to be the person
that he is the hero that he is and he's
gonna have help from his [ __ ] spider
friends and stuff so much so that at one
point mj falls off the statue of liberty
where they're having the big conclusion
the big fight where i thought they might
bump into the x-men in the gift shop and
[ __ ]
and as she's plummeting off you see
andrew garfield like freaked the [ __ ]
out his the amazing spider-man like no
and he [ __ ] saves it i thought that
was so [ __ ] dope
could have predicted it before i got in
the theater man once i saw that hand
shot in the trailer i was like there's
no way they don't let that guy make up
for [ __ ] gwen stacy and so that was
really sweet
um
seeing uh toby come back again like i
said earlier like those weren't really
my spider-man movies or my
you know i i love the marvel cinematic
universe stuff i have nothing but
respect for those movies but i wasn't
like a hardcore fan
this movie made me a fan of those movies
so much so that i went and back and
re-watched those flicks again
but seeing tobey maguire like slip into
the character again
um and into the suit and make like back
hurting jokes because remember at one
point he was like
almost not going to be in the movie like
over a man or something like that
when they were talking to jake
gyllenhaal at one point
um
and all their interplay together about
how you know he's got organic web
shooters as opposed to
those who would actually build their web
shooters and
like andrew garfield's like i have to
like make mine with chemistry like you
know
science um tom holland effortlessly
blending with those two andrew garfield
had one of the better lines in that
scene though i think where he's just
like i always wanted brothers i thought
that was so [ __ ] sweet man but you
have like three incarnations of a really
good guy like peter parker was just a
good guy at heart
and you've got three generations of
those actors that we've all seen play
these characters before
coming together there's a poignancy to
it beyond the content of just seeing
actors return to roles which we're going
to see a lot of over the course of the
next few years because they figured out
if you show us something you showed us
when we were kids we'll give you all the
[ __ ] money
so i know it's like you know
easy programming or low-hanging fruit to
be like we're gonna put all three
spider-man in one movie and we know
you're gonna pay for it
they did it but it wasn't cynical like
really kind of touching really
well done um
i absolutely bore the movie it's like i
said it's barely a movie and crosses
into
an event um if you haven't seen it yet
kids and you watch this
we told you
number one but number two see it as soon
as as you can uh and i'm not necessarily
one of those cats who's like see it on
the big screen like most better
filmmakers would tell you to do i'm just
as fine to watch [ __ ] at home but this
one
see it on the big screen man uh see it
with a bunch of people
that's that's the key not that it's
safely as you can
so yeah wear a hundred masks if you
gotta but like 100 masks ain't gonna
stifle the joy you feel we only have
like 10 12 people in our room and you
could still feel
the palpable [ __ ] joy
uh from time to time when [ __ ] matt
murdock caught a brick
without even [ __ ] looking and [ __ ]
come on everyone was like i'm a good
lawyer
every time somebody showed up oh
it's that movie man just like end game
it's sad it's just like snickers as well
uh so i give it like uh thwip whip
these many fingers up with
webs all over this picture
i really enjoyed it honestly like that
in hawkeye season finale i was like oh
[ __ ] marvel jeff yes how about you
captain
um uh you know it's it's what i think we
mentioned in walking out of the
screening that it's it's always easy to
forget especially the tom holland
incarnation of spider-man because so
much energy and so much like buoyancy
like he always seems [ __ ] thrilled to
be spider-man
but spider-man is a tragedy like
ultimately it's a tragic story you know
what every iteration of spidey has to
lose somebody in order to become
spiderman and so that moment where you
know the three
the three spideys the three peters are
on that roof
as peter is just despondent after having
lost may
you know like i lost my uncle too you
know i lost you know we've all lost
something every moment like each of us
there's also a moment that you got in
into the spider verse which i kept
thinking of a lot watching these movies
sort of back to back but that idea that
like yeah every spider-man has to lose
somebody it's usually an uncle ben for
miles it's his uncle aaron for for
spider gwen it's peter parker but they
all have to lose somebody and so and
watching that level of tragedy kind of
trace throughout the movie so the very
end when he makes that decision he's got
to give up the life that he wants in
order for the life that is right the
life that he has to leave and so he has
to give up the love of his life he has
to give up his best friend he's got to
give up everything to become a nobody in
a world that doesn't really care for him
and there's then like walking sad into
that apartment with you know how does he
have a job he's he's he's functionally
not a person in the world so he's living
in some weird like hell's kitchen flat
with his one box of stuff
trying to move in and start building a
life like that's sad as [ __ ]
but you know i love that they stuck to
those guns about spider-man they didn't
give you a rosy version of it that it's
always this kid hurts and he's always
hurting
um
i loved the beginning of this movie you
know i loved how they established that
his world is being broken you know and
what the cost of that is and how his
friends can't get into college so he
can't walk down the street of flash is
writing books about him all that stuff
is great and i loved the last act of the
movie like i think once the spider-man
show up and once it becomes you know
it's the three of them against the world
um and especially the post anime stuff
i think it's phenomenal um you know and
i love the the revo williams like deep
cut for those old nerds where they're
having their climactic fight on the
statue of liberty with scaffolding all
over it was like oh the 1980s kid in me
is so happy
um
i think you know for me where the movie
falters a little bit is that middle
section
where it's you know peter parker and his
to-do list of do i kill these dudes or
not kill them or just return them to
where they go or do i try to cure them
which seems
it it was never emotional for him in a
real way because none of the bad guys
were his bad guys like it became
academic like i i was hoping that we
would see vulture i was hoping we would
see mysterio i was hoping that
some of this threat would connect to him
in a way that wasn't abstract
you're right i didn't think about it so
wait his villains were
green goblin doc ock
electro sandman
and electrodes from the raymond movies
sandman and lizard
mark webb movies
um wow you're right he didn't have his
own
villain
yeah and so like so there's no
one in his own villains so the meeting
right tom holland that's crazy you're
right there's a
emotional
disattachment because there's no like
i've fought this cat before they mean
right you know and so
he's all like who who are they who are
you who are you who are you i don't know
who you are but i guess i should do the
right thing because i'm a hero as
opposed to
oh
i
i ruined your life
by like hey vulture dude remember how
your wife left you and your daughter
moved away and you were in prison and
maybe you killed yourself in prison
maybe there's some other multiverse
version of me that actually killed you
in combat or mysterio who did die and
like in this version he doesn't die and
all of that stuff then becomes personal
to him it doesn't become academic it
doesn't become distant
and to have that person be the one
to be responsible for killing aunt mate
so then it's his failure like his his
for real failure um to me just would
have made that deeper it would have made
it you know less kind of like
three men and a baby moving into happy's
bachelor pad so that they can like do
chemistry together like it's made a
bunch of villains trying to fix each
other like it got a little like rompy in
a way that like i get it there's got to
be a middle of a movie sure
you know the spell with doctor strange
like i don't know why doctor strange
doesn't tell peter from the jump hey man
if you're going to want to change this
like this is what's going to happen so
before i start doing hand [ __ ] in the
air you can tell me what do you want me
to do so it doesn't become an on the
floor like you're a grown up doctor
strange you know how magic works like i
buy peter wanting it but i also was kind
of hoping that doctor strange would have
been like hey man this is how this is
going to go down i think mark's point is
before you do any hand stuff you always
get permission
i'm going to do some hand stuff and it's
going to make everyone forget who you
are before he did the hand stuff you're
right you just got the dick move of
doctor strange to be like hey man yeah
we're going to fix this and how we're
going to fix this is going to [ __ ] your
life bobby's wait wait wait
like you can understand peter having
reservations at the last second trying
to throw in caveats
yeah you know and also like
not for nothing but a better wish would
have been
uh can you make it so mysterio never
existed
and that way there's nobody to give up
his secret there's nobody to broke acid
to the world you don't have to make
anybody forget nothing except that dude
and cares about that dude
he's dead anyway but
that's neither here nor there boys and
girls
um i thought about that
uh and i will say like a friend of mine
an old boss sean simmons texted me he's
like wouldn't it have been awesome if
happy showed up in an iron man suit to
punch the [ __ ] out of the green goblin
for killing the love of his life and i
was like yes it would have
give me angry happy and [ __ ] stark
text
angry happy angry happy
give me mad hogan with him showing up in
a hulkbuster shoot a suit yeah
that would have been nice you know but i
think that like you know to your point
to everybody's point where this movie
lands and how it resolves and how that
emotional story like because it's not
cameos these guys are not just bumping
into like wave and say look remember me
you know it is very much about their
stories too specifically the andrew
garfield um
one because i feel like he was he was
the
he was the great spider-man and not
great spider-man movies that nobody
gives any credit to and so to see him
actually like kind of spread out and own
the character and be funny and be
awkward and
and be tragic and to rip you know sort
of redeem himself a little bit like that
moment where he saves mj is wonderful
really because you realize that his it
has been haunting this guy for decades
that he didn't that he failed and so he
gets a chance to win
he is more enjoyable
as spider-man in 20 minutes of this
movie than i think he was in his
previous two movies there is a lightness
to his performance and i enjoyed him
as spider-man in those previous two
movies but
he is having a ball and it may be
because like hey this ain't my movie i'm
a guest star i get to
and you know i get to i don't it's i'm
not driving the narrative forward like
[ __ ] this kid is this time but number
one andrew garfield is a wonderful
[ __ ] actor just to begin with um he
does a great
uh jim baker in the uh eyes of tammy
faye that's out right now um and of
course we all loved him in the social
network and stuff but you know he's he's
charming as [ __ ]
in in no way home is and i'm not i'm not
raising him and lowering toby toby's
wonderful in his very tobey way but i
think andrew garfield was the surprise
for me and it sounds like for you too
where you walk on like
like he was the you know if you're
putting that together
he i'm not gonna say he's the
afterthought but the first person you
gotta get
is toby
because you showed up to the party and
you're like look who's back it's andrew
garfield spider-man people be like oh
awesome where's where's what about toby
is he there
because that's
so many people spider-man so they
delivered toby
and that allowed andrew to be like you
know
yeah i'm the other spider-man
and fill this space
that he he didn't get to fill before he
was fun and light i'm not saying he
wasn't fun in those other movies but
they it was i don't know it benefited
him
greatly
um
that
that uh
well i was going to say that toby was in
the movie but not as a comparison just
like if you don't get toby something
tells me they don't go for it you know
what i'm saying like right
you know that like the the spider the
mark webb spider-man movies weren't as
beloved as the sam raimi ones and toby
being the first spider-man it's like if
you don't land him
then we probably let the idea go all
together
i'm glad they landed them because it
allowed andrew garfield to shine in some
way totally yeah
i was listening interrupted back to you
no i was i was listening to a friend of
mine joanna robinson she was talking on
this podcast for the ring reverse
about how kevin feige's relationship to
all these spider-man movies are
different where for the toby movies he
was an assistant
like he was i think was aviarad's
assistant or something like that but he
was relatively low level he was in a lot
of meetings but never said anything
because that wasn't his job like he was
present but not vocal
for the for the mark webb um andrew
garfield movies he was an executive
producer
but not in a way that makes him that
they gave him any real power so he would
give notes that they ignored by and
large um because he was still like you
know iron man was happening the very
beginnings of the mcu as we know were
happening and he didn't have the juice
yet to kind of come in and say this is
how you should make a spider-man movie
and so by the time you get to the tom
holland movies he's the man like he's
got the power he's got the jews he's
like post avengers there's you know that
dude absolutely could then go to sony
and begin you know saying if we're gonna
make a spider-man movie i'm making your
spider-man movie with amy pascal of
course
and so to watch him
get to
do the andrew garfield version of
spider-man that he wanted to do that
nobody would listen to him and to get
him to position toby in the way that he
always felt like working under those
guys and and being with raymie at the
beginning and understanding that the
juice and the joy that he brought to it
him beginning to finally put his bow on
spider-man with every version that he's
had anything to do with is actually kind
of lovely and kind of wonderful um
if i had one thing
that i that i was hoping i would see but
didn't
um
it was
chris pines spiderman
you know peter parker like that guy the
blonde one be like the golden boy the
captain america of peter parker's
and i was fingers crossing for miles
morales you know and i know that that is
a much bigger
get and a much bigger
hill to climb because once you cast
live-action miles morales that's your
guy
and i'm sure that at some point sony's
going to go down that road
and i think i think though that it won't
be a multiverse decision like it feels
like they're going to put miles morales
into the same universe with the current
spider-man who i would assume at that
point would be tom holland right um i
for one would prefer that i would like
him to be the spider-man of earth prime
or whatever the [ __ ] they're calling or
was it earth 626 or something like mia
616. six months
um but yeah like i was just
like i kept one i'm like give me give me
the thing that i didn't know i was going
to get because i knew i was getting
angel and toby but what's that one
surprise that they didn't manage to keep
under wraps because everything else
leaked like a sieve at social security
it's like oh yeah we got it we got a
matt murdock sure yeah we got all these
bad guys yep and we got three three
spider-man okay what else are we doing
oh no that's about it there's nothing
else to tell anybody yeah it was there
was no i mean the story line was
surprising and as much as like oh he's
gonna try to kill them all stuff um you
knew someone was gonna perish
and um you know
it's
a lot of people speculated before the
movie it's going to be happy but it's
like i don't know
it's going to be happy much as somebody
very close to him as we see that's what
happened
but uh they it was funny because it
played very much like a light movie
in as much as you know like um
it's not end game serious very like
there's some levity to it and then it
does turn and game serious at one point
you get um you know tom holland
spider-man about to [ __ ] behead
norman osborne
his own glider and stuff and then toby
has to to friendly neighborhood
spider-man has to stop him to tell him
like it ain't worth it don't do it and
stuff like that yeah and they [ __ ]
tag
green goblin instead and give them the
cure and stuff like that like that is so
out of the comics you know what i'm
saying like i've read those comics
[ __ ] kids
and it was never like spider-man's like
i'm gonna [ __ ] kill him like it was
always like i gotta help these people
yeah i mean i think the other thing that
that i was thinking and it only occurred
to me now
is that if the spell is conjuring and
bringing forth everybody who knows that
peter parker is spider-man
then it should not have brought only
villains
and so
like that moment when he's about to kill
green goblin and the other spider-man
are trying to implore him not to
how amazing would it have been if
another aunt may walked in and another
aunt may walked in and all of the ant
mays either it's the sally fields or
it's the little tomlins or the whatever
that's not fair don't write about it
[ __ ] scene but you're right that
would have been real especially
considering he lost a man he just lost
his anime so a bunch of animes show up
and say peter this is not you kid like i
know you're angry you're just as angry
as you were when you lost your uncle ben
but this isn't the way with great power
like a chorus of with great powers come
great responsibilities and then
everybody just weeps and cries and i
would prefer that over
dr strange still having to do flashy
things in the sky like the standard
marvel ending where there's got to be
big special effects there's got to be
whatever it's like no dude just remind
this kid who he's supposed to be
remind this kid who he is
and that that that to me is
and it happens like the movie gives you
that
but just that little little extra frizz
on and i know that there's you know
there's there's still frames online that
i've seen it's like yeah there was the
rhino who's going to come through and
there's there's a ghost image of craven
the hunter that was going to come
through like all the villains we haven't
seen yet or only saw as like russians
and robot suits
um
but yeah like honestly those are those
are somewhat small nits to pick um and i
do it only because i know the internet
expects me to
but i did love this movie
um it's a wonderful flick man um
let me see the uh
bam
yeah oh
i'm just gonna say uh because we spent a
lot of time talking about
uh tom holland and andrew garfield toby
was my spider-man
um
who i loved and uh i just want to point
out a couple of my favorite parts
was uh that he showed up as a youth
pastor
and maybe for
10 minutes you watched him in his
street clothes
to the point that
they convinced me i'm like oh my god
he's he's not gonna
we're gonna get this we're not gonna get
him in the suit and they almost broke
that fourth wall with andrew garfield
who's like you're gonna you're gonna web
slinging that
oh i get the suit
i loved that moment i thought was great
and i thought that
for being what a 45 year old man now 50
year old close to it um
that toby slipped back into peter parker
really well i agree
um
reminding you like oh yeah the reason
like that performance really really
worked like there's something kind of
touching and awkward about him even as a
grown-up
at this point a grown-up version of
peter parker
um yeah and then the
the two biggest hitters for me where
when andrew got to save
mj
uh was
that's what got me going and then the
other time
was they gave you
right at the end
a hint of the danny elfman score
for toby and i that was
oh
um i love that the one thing i didn't
see that i was hoping i got to see
was when tom holland gets his apartment
i wanted to see
the landlord from toby's movie
uh the uh how nice was that [ __ ]
andrew garfield moment where he's like
where he talks about pulling his punches
he's like and then i stopped pulling my
punches
it was [ __ ] dark man for especially
for like a family yeah spider-man movie
it was kind of nice really like they let
him have that it feels like you know
maybe in retrospect that guy's like look
i never got a third spider-man movie so
my closure is going to be here
and he brought it in a big bad way and
big wonderful
so much so that like now i'm like
make more of that
you know what i'm saying like bring them
all back i mean like all at this point
i would say anything's possible and if
they're game i would watch now i would
watch another toby maguire [ __ ]
spider-man set in that universe i'd
watch another andrew garfield spider-man
set in his universe like this multiverse
thing is a character for these cats
can we get the thing that i want now is
the spider-man christmas special
where like they all come back you know
because [ __ ]
ned figures out a sling ring you know
whoever once what spider-man reminds his
friends who he is or reminds dr strange
who is just the idea that they all show
up to peter's sad sad apartment
to spend his first christmas alone
with with tom holland's peter i think
it's just really really sweet
uh dipsy-doo and chat keeps saying over
and over kevin filipinos finally got
their shine yes ned
became a huge hero in this and there's
speculation about like will ned
go bad in the movie like he never has
that one moment where they talk about
like my friend
like turned into the you know what
became a villain and died in my arms and
stuff like that and you're like oh no
are they gonna play with that instead
ned wound up as a big uh a big hero uh
in the flick so i guess that's what
what dipsy dude is talking about and
it was named jacob battle and he did
another great job as it is zendaya she's
wonderful
uh as mj has really grown into the
character remember in the first movie
she's just all kind of
sarcasm
she's very emo
but here
you buy their relationship um
i was happy with that the uh
let's see what else sam can i can i
pitch my
amazing spider-man spin-off
yeah you get the actor who played iceman
from
the marvel movies you cast fire star
you do
amazing spider-man and his amazing
friends with andrew garfield
nice i like that
spider-man's amazing friends one of my
all-time favorite iterations of
spider-man in terms of where this la is
in the spider-man pantheon of movies
um i put it at the top shoulder shoulder
width into the spider-verse into the
spider-verse probably edges it out a
little bit because they went first and
it's so incredibly imaginative and they
have to tell their story using you know
not
the the [ __ ] free spider-mans that
you've come to love over years but some
spider characters that you hadn't heard
prior to that incarnation um
and just you know
but it edges it out just by a little bit
both of those are
top two for me man um
it was a wonderful time [ __ ] satisfying
and you know as a tough landing to stick
and they stuck it spider-man styled like
one hand up in the air
one hand down on the ground man it's
crazy wonderful
yeah i still think it's
something it's spider-verse homecoming
and then no way home for me
um because i think homecoming
it's so john huesey it's so this kid is
down in his luck it's so
come on spider-man you could do with
spider-man just those moments
of him becoming
you know
like really owning being that hero you
know even without tony stark because
tony yanks all the tech from him about
halfway through the movie
you know and then that's my favorite
moment i think in the tom holland
spider-man cycle is
him trying to get up after the vulture
knocks a building on him and he goes
come on peter come on spider-man
come on spider-man oh it makes me
[ __ ] cry like thinking about it as he
says he's pushing [ __ ] up come on
spider-man i will never
ever be that strong in my life not even
physically just like [ __ ]
psychologically where he's psyching
himself up man like oh i love that
moment it's so awesome
yeah you know and i love that moment
when it's peter
in the car with the vulture
and it's when the vulture discovers
right in like real time that like this
kid is spiderman when he goes
good old spider spiderman
i'm gonna have a word here with uh with
peter here
now you go in there and you show my
daughter a good time but not too good a
time
yeah
um but no i really really dug it i uh
you know i i will always find a thing or
two
but you know as we always say as i
always say to any rate is that you can
love a thing and still criticize it
and loving a thing for its imperfections
is even better than it being perfect
dipsy do corrected me says no kevin i'm
talking about the grandma speaking
tagalog with no subtitles
also very cool very cool
everybody got what they wanted in this
movie
what we wanted in this movie then they
showed us a [ __ ] trailer for doctor
strange at the end of the movie i know i
know really think about it weird man
like that that's a
as a disney movie being advertised on a
sony film
yeah but it's also a marvel movie so
yeah
very true just because sony got there
like we're still trying to make mark
give a [ __ ] about venom
mid-credit scene
even though it doesn't work
i still don't give a [ __ ] about venom
you can't make me do it you can't you
can't give me a little scene with with
[ __ ] eddie brock at a bar
you know
being yanked back into his own verse
leaving a little shred of venom goo
behind
hey here's my question about um you know
the whole world forgets the peter parker
spider-man
what about the mysterio video
it's one thing to erase a memory but
like
that spell alters video footage as well
apparently
magic is the greatest hack
fair enough
yeah i would have i would have you know
and you guys are all like this is what i
wanted i would have appreciated a line
saying such like
just clarify this for me please yeah
like magic took care of that video as
well
man um good times ladies and gentlemen
yes that's that [ __ ] trailer for
doctor strange looks fantastic a lot
more mordo a lot more wanda we saw some
uh uh america
chavez miss america yes and apparently
the dark doctor strange from what if was
not just relegated to the cartoon now
that's just that dude now yeah maybe
they're bringing him into this as well i
bet you there's going to be a bunch of
strangers in this movie man like the
multiverse of blindness so he may have
to fight
different versions of himself
i one can only hope
um yeah man no way home
no way
you should miss it
uh all right so are you ready do you
have feelings about a a top nine ranked
of marvel's 2021 offerings
because i got mine i can run through
mine if you want all right you go first
and then i'll follow first well i'll see
if i agree with you all right number
nine i'm gonna count down to one
number nine eternals
that's of nine of nine nine of nine i
agree with that
yeah just could not work up a ton of
enthusiasm for eternals
number eight
loki
which is um i'd have to hear the rest of
the list okay
number seven
falcon in the winter soldier
okay
number six
one division
that's
lower than i would put it would keep
going
number five what if
okay
number four black widow
okay
number three chongqi
okay
number two hawkeye
wow
late comer raising so high in the
rankings latecomer raising high number
one spiderman no way
um i'll go in the reverse so i would
agree spider-man no way home would be my
number one marvel movie for this year of
the nine that were released
um after that i would go wanda vision
so i really loved one division um
then let's see
um
did i like
hawkeye more than
than
yeah i guess i liked hawkeye more than
falcon and the winter soldier
like i you know so i it edges out just a
little bit so that would be three and
four
um then maybe black widow at five
because i've watched that four times i
really like the opening sequence
[Music]
then
what if it's six
um we know that
the eternals is nine so what's missing
for seven and eight uh shang chi and
loki
uh wow then loki would be eight for me
and
and uh
i might i might move shanxi up the list
and drop of
one or two down then and if that's the
case because i'm trying to think let me
see
spider-man juan division
you know i put shanxi at three actually
man i had a good [ __ ] time watching
that with my wife
um you know when i've watched it when i
was just awake for a whole year
uh so that would be three then four
would be hawkeye five would be
uh uh falcon in the winter soldier
six would be
black widow
seven would be what if
eight would be
loki and nine would be
generals eternals
checks out
yeah i mean uh
we're we're closer than i think maybe we
thought we'd be
but yeah especially like i thought we
diverged completely on loki but like
loki's pretty low on my list too and not
because i'm like oh i like it just i
like some of their other things so much
more
yeah
yeah you know in my one division
um as i i like where it ended but it
took me too long to to get where it was
going
you know like there's i got rationales
maybe i'll post them on twitter why why
they ended where they ended but yeah it
has been a strong year
um and maybe this is the most marvel
we've ever gotten in a year
and hell if it wasn't a year we needed
it and this is what phase four we're in
this is phase four we're in yeah
which kicked off with one division
um
scott of casterly rock and chad is
saying hawkeye did kingpin dirty and yes
i know what happens in the comics
um well you know i mean look
you know there's the they there's a bit
of wiley coyote there at the end with
the explosions and stuff but he is a
gigantic man
um he really is and they're playing him
in the disney plus universe you know as
a little more arch than you know he was
in the netflix version
yeah
giving him
a nice touch for
we long time comic book fans
yeah
and i probably didn't even need that
last scene where maya shoots him where
echo shoots him
um because i like to hit just his body
being gone
because we're not gonna kill the kingpin
we know he's gonna be around but i also
know that they needed to position echo
clearly as a sort of
on the side of heroism to give her her
own show so she shoots kingpin in the
chest and like oh we buy it
but he still can't be dead because you
don't bring him in there for a scene and
a half and then kill him
victor venn diagram in chat says i think
echo pulled the trigger on kingpin
next to his ear to make him deaf so
kingpin is still alive but disabled i'll
take that
yeah that's cool that is [ __ ] cool
um but he'll definitely be back for sure
uh you don't just introduce you know
[ __ ] vincent d'onofrio and be like ah
there he is ladies and gentlemen
thanks for stopping by
um i think he was blind in the comics at
one point
i remember correctly
to better match with daredevil
yes
um
yeah scott fitzgerald and chet says he
also wears bulletproof suits that's why
the arrow just kind of
women's stuff yeah they established that
on the netflix show
um for those people
who didn't uh
you know watch
the bulletproof hawaiian shirts
for wine shirts
um he looks big they shot him big bigger
than
like like
lots of locations
shots oh oh and uh
you know it helps i don't know how tall
haley stanfield is but
she uh
she at one point he dwarfed her in a
shot and i was like this looks like the
comic book version of of kingpin
i like i like to pay off with the uh
flicking of the quarter
to to set off all of the broken trick
arrows that was sweet
and uh dark ronin yeah the alpha kingpin
wares is from a spider-man comic called
family business
the hawaiian outfit
it was a weird touch like him in the
hawaiian shirt
i mean maybe he's just feeling tropical
in the middle of new york winter
um alex bpm2 said how any list can
possibly include eternals and falcon and
winter soldiers beyond me
well the list was about the nine marvel
thing we ranked the nine things marvel
put out so we had to included in the
list in order for the list
to be what the thesis was based on do
you understand this isn't predicated on
like we love these this is predicated on
these are the things that came out and
this is how we would rank them
so it doesn't matter if it is as you
call it bottom of the barrel woke
garbage
we still have to list the nine in the
order that we wanted to list him in
order to complete the thesis does that
track
i think so an attack on you and the
things that you don't like it's just
the idea of we had to rank nine so we
rank nine that's that's all boy well you
got disclaimer [ __ ] everything don't
you
well
apparently
um should we get into a quick flick at
that matrix
um
yeah
yeah i guess we we could totally we
could totally do that
yeah and then we'll read our second ad
and then we'll do some q a and then
we'll go have lots of eggnog kyle carter
says we're both on crack if loki isn't
in our top three
hand me that pipe
yeah like
why
like why
how come why how come i'm not sitting
here going you must be on crack because
it isn't your top three like
god damn it man like i know it's the
internet but can you just say a thing
without ever be buddy
[Music]
and again it wasn't even like this is my
ranking of everything for the year it's
like there were nine mark did anybody
here [ __ ] mark's thesis
there's nine marvel projects this year
we're just going to put them in the
order that we enjoyed them best
christ
back the [ __ ] off man jesus
anyway
anywho
sammy you're getting so about the
weirdest stupidest [ __ ]
the um the wonderful thing about getting
eight or nine marvel projects in a
single year
is that people can pick their three
favorite and not watch the other stuff
right like there's something for
everybody this year
you know you don't need to be crappy to
other people because they like different
things
mark had a good idea
about ranking nine things and that
really upset some people
because something was always going to be
at the bottom
i guess and again we weren't even saying
like this is dog [ __ ] it's just in
ranking order of personal preference oh
my god
kids
like
life's too short to get that
bigger about something uh all right so
uh matrix res resurrections is that
resurrections yes
is uh you could go see it in the movie
theater right now
and as a filmmaker i should be telling
you to do that
uh so go do that but you could be like
me and watch it on home on hbo max which
i did this afternoon
um
and uh you will see another matrix movie
man
uh they did it they brought the matrix
back and
eradicated it reminded me the whole time
i was watching it it reminded me of
remember that
nightmare on elm street they did that
wes craven was in it too oh yeah west
coast new nightmare was that it was that
it i think i was thinking it was the new
nightmare it this i'm not saying like
this [ __ ] movie was taken from that
but it reminded me of that in itself
awareness
very meta i don't i am not going to
spoil this movie at all the way we
spoiled spider-man and stuff because
there's very little you can say about
this movie without
spoiling everything because last time we
saw these characters
spoilers they [ __ ] died so it's like
how's this all happening so there's i'm
not gonna go into how it's all happening
see the movie it's definitely uh worth
seeing for that but they did they they
opened the matrix for business again
um and it tracked for me the whole thing
i was like yeah yeah yep yep yep yep um
you know
better movie than any oliver [ __ ]
make that's for damn sure uh looked
expensive as [ __ ] god they spent a dime
or two
they did
um it's nice to get into that
pseudo-psychology again you know we're
like wait are we real are we like you
got to remember when the first one came
out
all these ideas were incredibly new
now you know
if i can just sign online and somebody
will give you a theory about how we're
living in a simulation and stuff based
on local matrix so it's it's funny to
see how
self-aware they are of their legacy
um
and how they work it in is very clever i
thought it was very clever in terms of
like oh
all right i see what you're doing here
that's a great way in
to the story um
and uh
it's self-referential it's almost as
self-referential as a [ __ ] kevin
smith movie
i mean there is a sequence where and not
to spoil it too much where somebody
invokes the name warner brothers
yes
that [ __ ] blew my mind at one point
and i was like
oh my god this is the matrix reboots
like it's it's very there are a few
moments where you think they might turn
to the camera and be like
look what we made
but uh it doesn't strain caduality when
they do it but it is
like
how they've
found a way to weave it into our world i
thought was really really interesting
how we go on the journey in the first
place i thought was clever like you know
i remember want to see in the first
trailer i was like how do we get from
what i saw at the end of the matrix
trilogy
to this and how they took us there i
didn't see coming and i enjoyed very
much i mean you know in the trailer they
gave us hints but but the movie itself
as they unfold their big [ __ ] map
it's you know it's a journey that's
that's worth
worth taking
uh i have not finished said matrix uh
resurrections i started this afternoon
and didn't quite realize that the bite
that i was chewing off of there
um
i will say and without spoiling too much
um
there's a really interesting
conversation the movie wants to be
having in the first half of it
which is very much what the original
matrix was which is real and which is
not real you know and and if you have a
choice whether or not to go from one or
the other um
i feel like there's a version of this
movie where you don't know which version
is real and which version isn't
but this movie actually sets up pretty
clearly
that the one thing that could be fake is
not fake and so your character's main
dilemma doesn't seem quite as ambiguous
you know
again trying not to spoil too much but
it sets
it begins setting the reality of the
endeavor so it's never really a question
um
i think it's a bit messy
you know in in in the way it starts to
peel off some of its revelations of its
information and
and some of its character stuff
but i will say every scene that you get
with keanu reeves and carrie anne moss
is lovely
and it makes me wonder why i have not
seen more carry and moss outside of them
the marvel netflix stuff i read a story
she uh had kids she had a family so she
was like you know i did enough acting
for the most so she slowed down on
acting and went and raised a family good
for her like i applaud the decision but
it
she is so good
and so kind of like effortlessly good
and i say that you know
probably a little condescendingly
but
it seems as if she's just a natural at
this um and so even when she just enters
the screen when you see the two of them
together it just it has a spark to it
and like he sparks up to it because it's
again it's supposed to be about a guy
reconnecting with the love of his life
um
you know and i think it it tries to do
this thing and i'm not sure yet how
successful it is about reminding you of
the first movie without comparing itself
to it
right which is interesting trick to try
and do and when i say remind you i mean
literally cutting in footage
of
those first couple of movies um
which is which is you know it's always
that bit like at the end of a biopic
when you've been seeing actors playing
the real person and then they cut to the
real person at the end you're like oh
so that's what she looked like
okay
i suppose that was close enough
and so to be seen characters
who are supposed to be one or the other
um
yeah it's just
it might be calling my attention too
much for the fact that this isn't bad
um
i will watch the end of this movie
simply because i'm a matrix completist
um
and then i will figure out if how i feel
about it compared to the other matrix
sequels it so far is not the first movie
um and i'm not sure that any matrix
people could be the first movie because
so much of that required us to not know
what the [ __ ] was going on
it demanded some semblance of being lost
and then finding your way through the
movie and the more you know about the
world the less the harder is to get you
lost the more it has to literally just
leave you a bit adrift
um
on the information superhighway to get
lost but
i'll finish it because i'm that guy and
i'm always here for keanu reeves and i'm
my rediscovered appreciation of carrion
moss will power me through
um but it's a weird one
there is uh in chat there's some folks
who are
saying uh
let me see uh v1 ll
1n i guess
it does not look like you are impressed
at all
there is zero excitement in your vibes
um i i'm trying not to spoil the movie
that's that's
why
i i said i liked it i thought it was
totally journey worth taking
and i was in my [ __ ] bedroom watching
it so it's not like it was any skin off
my ass it was you know two and a half
hours
of time well spent i thought so if
you're not reading that any excitement i
mean i didn't like as much as [ __ ]
spider-man obviously but
marvel [ __ ]
um but i'm trying also not to
talking about the movie is giving the
movie away because it's a you know it's
a it's a little puzzle box of a flick
and
so that's all don't misread that is like
lack of excitement uh jason mckibbin
says fat man beyond has been the
greatest joy of my life in 2021 thank
y'all oh my god that is so sweet
we like doing the show so that's really
nice to hear and stuff
um
what is this lord corporal says kevin
you deserve the backlash i don't know
what backlash he's talking about
um
if you were talking about me when i was
like why are people talking about our
list of nine then i don't think you
understand that i was
bending mark's thesis of like we were
just ranking the nine things so i don't
know if that's
backlash i have no idea what backlash
you referred to um
the uh
let's see the um
oh for attorney it says mo to season two
where are we at with that kev uh
fingers crossed
i i know much as you do with this but
that's not true i know a lot more but
i'm still waiting to hear
uh something so as soon as i know
something believe me i got a big mouth
i'll let you know something as well
uh
can i use this opportunity kevin to
clear up something that's been nagging
at me please do it oh god it's your
fault as much as mine and i feel like
it's a it's an end of the year it's a
good end of the year conversation yeah
yeah
is it
fat
man beyond
three words
or is it fat man beyond two words i
always thought it was three words based
on the fact that like it's not batman
which is one word it's fat man
beyond um and i think when it was fat
man on batman it was fat
man on batman
so it's three words to me why do you no
it's been two it's two words it's two
words to me
look at you man
guys live in the same reality so
completely far apart
just because there was always a uh sort
of silvery k
uh you know
a a what is the what is the word for
that when you make up a word but it was
based on batman which is one word and so
fat man also values one word
but
i uh
i i i stand corrected this this was your
podcast before it was our podcast and
you set the tone in the tempo so if it's
three words i will i will adjust
accordingly i'm also not passionate
enough to
you know
but if you look at the logo like on
screen
like one that's above your head on the
on the youtube channel
like
the f and the m are bigger than the a
and the and
seeming to indicate two separate words
two separate words but that's just me
um what a [ __ ] i can't believe that's
been bugging you this long and like
you haven't thought to ask until now
and you're like is it three or two words
instead you're like i got a soul-searing
question to end the year
well it's one of those like it doesn't
bother me enough to remember that it
bothers me um you know like i'll think
about it i'll read something or whatever
and like oh is it three words and then
it just completely skips my mind
but now i don't know why it dug in maybe
because we weren't doing any real news
today and i had more brain space
but um but i'm glad we got to the bottom
of that look problem solved like
gentlemen
hyper hex says can we talk about elvis
now
mark will sign off if we start to start
talking about elvis again hyper
fam
oh batman is here what's up we uh
we have failed to mention
that we are less than one week away from
book of boba fett though
is that all right is that when it
started oh my god what a great [ __ ]
time of year man like [ __ ] you could
watch the matrix at home if you got hbo
max hawkeye just finished up
spider-man's in a movie theater and now
we got [ __ ] more star wars coming our
way
tues tuesday at midnight
tuesday so of next week
yeah if we uh also plug uh if you're in
los angeles
uh we're doing twin sun tuesdays
for two dollar tacos two dollars off
blue milk
two dollars off binary sunset pale ale
and if you come
repping boba fett we give you an
additional two dollars off
all night
and if you hang out till midnight
we will not be showing
anything that disney owns
nice
no it's like we'll have to reschedule
our podcast then we can't [ __ ] with two
dollar two sons twin sons tuesdays
we the podcast is a special event so
that will pick up after fat man beyond
ends
yeah
okay
so wait a second tuesday
is when it begins how many episodes
booker boba anybody know
uh
i
um
i do but i don't think i can say they
haven't they haven't announced it yet i
don't think it's been announced yet we
do know our boy dave klein shot it dp
dave klein baby dave himself who shot
clerks maul rats chasing amy i would bet
book of boba is more than four but less
than 10.
there you go i will confirm that
[Laughter]
decent enough guess
if you've not seen spider-man no way
home and therefore have not seen
everyone in chat is saying it's seven
episodes
yes it is chad is correct
chad is correct if uh you've not seen uh
spider-man and hence i've not seen the
trailer for
doctor strange and in the multiverse of
madness they put the trailer up online
today
so you can watch the [ __ ] flat out
trailer and stuff
uh just as thrilling as it was to see it
in the movie theater
um
all right
should we do our last ad and then get
into some q a let's do it man the second
half of this show
ladies and gentlemen uh it's sponsored
by
who is it mark
it is manscaped our favorite producer of
ball trimmers we love the good folks at
manscaped man oh my god they make our
balls look so fresh and pretty
nothing wrong with that
in the very least
but
so pretty
manscaped ladies and gentlemen go to
manscaped.com
right now if you want to follow along
um manscaped.com probably
uh there's a there's a song
i'm gonna click on this link here
and probably bring me up a google doc
there you go
there it is there it is
now manscape tends to do some good uh
copy don't they
you know they they've been known to
to tweak a word or two and make a little
make a little piff happen
uh kids if you want to follow along go
to manscaped.com
[Music]
fat man i believe that's our code right
you're gonna get 20 off with free
shipping by going to
manscape.com man
you're gonna have a happy new year for
your balls here's the copy that the good
folks and manscaped have come up with
for this week hey fellas uh this episode
of uh fat man beyond is brought to you
by our favorite producers of ball
trimmers manscape global leaders and
below the waist grooming are leaving
2021 with new product clean yourself
into the new year with their ultra
premium body wash which i've used also
special offer alert go to manscape.com
fatman for 20 off and free shipping at
manscape.com four million men
already trust manscape time to join in
oh man they didn't give us any uh fun
copy no the the first talking point is
pretty good though
uh let's see 2022 is on its way and the
last thing you want is to be the guy
with pubes getting in your way of making
this year your best yet
holy [ __ ] could you imagine if you're
like the only difference between me
having the best year yet and now
is my out of control [ __ ] pubes i've
got to get them under control is this
this horse sized bush
2021 sucked and that's why manscaped are
making a splash and upping your grooming
game and their signature lawnmower 4.0
is here to take down every pube in its
path that's right don't you want a crew
cut right over your deck
they're amazing the good folks at
manscape uh let's talk about being clean
feeling and smelling good the new ultra
premium
body wash from manscape ladies and
gentlemen solves all three for the
perfect addition to your daily grooming
routine but in the shower you do it in
the shower
where you do your private business i
shower every day and i hope you do too
that's not true i shower as often as i
can
if i'm going out i shower but if i'm
staying home and [ __ ] days will go by or
i don't shower yeah uh this body's uh
wash is infused with aloe vera ooh and
sea salt to keep your skin oil yeah some
of that sea salt you read about ke see
just keep your skin feeling clean nice
and moisturized with manscape you'll be
a brand new man and ready to kick all
the gross hair and smells out of out 20
21. so you know what they don't tell you
they never tell you that all salt is sea
salt
is that right
yeah kind of
they don't
they don't like carve it out of the
white cliffs of dover or some sort of
[ __ ] i mean even that used to be in the
sea and so that's where the salt comes
from
check you out you learn some [ __ ] on the
show you do
i mean yeah you can fake artificial salt
i suppose but even still it's
it's salt water that you're just drying
and getting salt out of it even table
salt even iodized salt i even even
mccormick's iodized salt oh my god yeah
i know when it rains in the world
wait till the chat tells me i'm wrong
go to
manscape.com for 20 off and free
shipping off your order man order a
bunch cause these cats are always so
good to us they keep sponsoring on our
show so thank you to everybody out there
who must be
patronizing the good folks at manscape
because they would not return
if they weren't seeing results so i
guess a lot of you out there got some
hairy nuts so
our fans are bush league
yeah thanks for [ __ ] uh making
manscaped
come back to us time and time again man
get 20 percent off free shipping by
going to manscape.com
20 off with free shipping by going to
manscape.com
fat man happy new year to you nuts
[Music]
manscaped for sponsoring the second half
of
fat man beyond uh if you're just joining
us kids
mark is trapped in the bathroom and the
shining and the baby
she's still in the tub she hasn't gotten
up yet so so far so good but we got to
wrap the show up before she pulls that
curtain over gets up and
first looks real good and then looks
real bad yeah
it's going down she's an old lady and
she gets out of tub and she's like ah
that's what i look like naked mark in
case you were ever wondering
dead sexy
um all right you know what we do in this
part of the show kids we do some q
and
a
uh the uh the three sweetest
letters or sweet two sweetest letters
with an ampersand between them
um we don't pick the questions we let jc
do that so that people get mad at him
i'm taking enough [ __ ] apparently
which i don't know what about but
[ __ ] yes so jc is gonna pick three
questions
from you the audience and uh give them
to us the hosts and we're gonna try to
answer them to the best of our damn
abilities if we were doing this
in uh the the scum and villainy cantina
why you'd walk away with some tickets to
a 40x screening or screen x screening
but since we're doing it online
you get [ __ ] you get the marvel no prize
i like that i think mir mir krios in
chat said with great balls there must
come great responsibility i thought that
was adorable what i think is adorable is
that you're finally [ __ ] reading chat
and joining in like me man
i wanted to give you a present for for
the end of the year thank god you waited
all year to give me that present man you
actually looked in on chat you're like i
would like to communicate a chat thought
hello mere cricos
with great balls must also come great
responsibility as huge you mark's never
done that before so mere close well done
yes you win
um all right
banff man what do we got man
all right well since we are on the eve
of christmas eve uh russell cook sent in
the question if santa was forced to sit
out christmas which comic book character
would be the best bet to deliver
presents
superman or flash
but superman can carry
the presence you know
barry or wally whoever the flash is he's
got strength but he's more fast than
anything else so it's great to have a
guy with speed but unless he's towing
the [ __ ] sleigh himself
i think superman i mean think about this
we know that superman can turn back time
and [ __ ] we've seen it
so even if he's late and he's like look
i got a backdoor out of this man i'm
superman
you know [ __ ] hitless [ __ ]
superman don't wake up and [ __ ] take
a [ __ ] without a [ __ ] backup plan
and that that's a quote from i think
action comics number two
[Laughter]
or i'm conflating that with the red
october i'm not sure
my pick is uh superman
i'm torn a bit because at first i went
nightcrawler
um this was a great choice banff in and
out of a bunch of houses i just don't
know
how much bamfing that poor man could do
before he just bants himself out and
just just [ __ ] tired and weeping in
the snow
um then i was like oh multiple man like
if you could just put seven billion
people at every door and just knock and
then deliver then you're not taking any
time at all
but i was like but i want to slay i feel
like a sleigh is important and so then i
thought about the main man i thought
lobo lobo and his intergalactic of a
motorbike feels like he's pretty close
to santa claus
but in a darker more homicidal way
hmm
um i like this i heard a noise outside
the room that's why i was
uh we're supposed to be getting rain and
my wife is battening down the hatches
we live in l.a kids where like the
moment anyone sees a drop of water
everyone freaks out and stuff so very
much so
we can get leaky so when we hear rains
coming it's like oh no we got
bad water karma in this house get out
the buckets what about if you had a
group effort what if it wasn't one
person for example if you had the
avengers doing it so you can have
ant-man shrinking all the presents down
to a carriable size
and then uh
uh
um who's the eternal that's super fast
um so sadly enough no no another guy
was it
mccarrick
how did you get into quicksilver right
yeah that's true there's quicksilver as
well wanda could be very helpful in this
tony stark would try to come up with a
technological fix but turn it into a
[ __ ] robot that tries to kill us all
so we'd better leave him off off of the
plan
um magic might be better i mean santa's
magic anyway so maybe we should be
looking at magic characters so and i was
just thinking about morpheus
i mean a he would know exactly what you
want because he can peep in on your
dreams and b
wouldn't a good dream
be a fantastic christmas present
could you imagine you [ __ ] caught
santa and he looked like morpheus
in that
black guy
giant [ __ ] suit draped around him
um i like that answer i like both
answers i like the fact that we had
answers it's a good question if we were
at the cantina we'd give you something
but you'd win tickets in a poster from
dark nate returns i'll give you some of
that there you go
um all right what do we got next there
jc that's a good question
uh jim chapman asks um a lot of people
want to see toby and andrew back uh i
pitched my movie earlier which was
nice thank you
uh my movie with spiderman and his
amazing friends jim chapman wants to
know what uh
what how do you want to incorporate toby
and andrew back into
the mcu
give them give them their encore
performance
um i say
look at this point
i say
like go back to doing what everyone was
going to do there was going to be a
spider-man 4.
make spider-man 4. there is going to be
an amazing spider-man 3.
make him now like you know just pick up
where he left off i mean now they know
there's a multiverse or whatever
but
it just seems that like you know this
movie's easily it's
gonna cross a billion fairly soon
worldwide
within like with ten days of its release
clearly there's a hunger
for those two guys playing those
characters you probably i don't know if
you can mince another billion dollar
movie off their backs but
you know you can definitely pull it off
right like for and also you're not
talking about
like these guys fighting world
threatening avengers level kind of bad
guys right like friendly neighborhood
spider-man an amazing spider-man
keeps it close to the ground which means
it could be cheaper than a tom holland
spider-man mm-hmm so you can make one
for like less than a hundo and stuff
wind up cleaning up real nice i i would
just do the sequels you know everyone
has heard about what was going to be
next let them go forward with their
plans now i would say
the characters have proven that they've
earned another shot if those actors want
to do it again you know maybe toby's
like look
[ __ ] that was enough i'm good and
maybe andrew garfield was like oh i'm
finished but like i
i don't know if they called me and they
were like hey we want to make another
one i'd be like [ __ ] yes so maybe
there's a part of them that would feel
that way too
but yeah and so the sequel the
spider-man 4
i know was gonna have uh bruce campbell
playing mysterio in a quick scene i
don't know who the bad guy was gonna be
the big bad though i think it was
vulture they were talking about it being
vulture
um larry david if i remember correctly
at one point wow
um and i don't know what the spider-man
3 or amazing spider-man 3 bad guy was
going to be
uh
i gotta plug my shelf in you talked so
long i'm out of juice
no no
no no here's yes talk about clothes i'm
losing power go ahead you talk
um personally i i want i want toby and
andrew to get back together for a marvel
disney plus tv show
that's a sitcom
like like like odd couple or perfect
strangers
where just it's an older spider-man and
a middle-aged spider-man like now
they're roomies because both their mjs
left them and so where i'm where am i
gonna live well i met this other guy and
you know we keep similar hours and
and then it's oh you're in my spider
suit mine's bigger yours is tighter in
the crotch well blah blah blah i think i
think there's just nothing but fun to be
had with two spideys living together
getting into dumb domestic adventures
and then there's some bigger [ __ ] at the
end it's like oh vulture's back oh it's
it's the blob
yeah we got some mothers punishers here
that's what a lot of folks in chat are
saying that uh the amazing spider-man 3
was gonna be the sinister six
ah so [ __ ] sign me up i'm all for it
yeah man i'm still here i'm still here
for the sitcom
[Music]
we've been waving we've been webbing for
you
all the kisses are hers and hers and
bears
two's company two
on november 23rd peter parker was asked
to leave his home
[Music]
[Laughter]
sounds like there should be a third in
this whipple
well there
there will be which mj's my mj will
share the mj
um that's true like in a world where
everyone who knew peter parker was
coming through they could have brought
back kirsten dunst
but uh you know time this didn't have
the time
how much money are we gonna spend did
you get the impression at the end of
spider-man that they were gonna reveal
that jay jonah jameson was mysterio
that's what i thought because they did
the shot of him at the end where he's
just like you know they were doing life
after people forgot
or was oh i guess it's the wind is
blowing something fierce already
um but uh the uh you know they you saw
the book the the the school book where
peter got his ged or whatever to [ __ ]
because he misses graduation because
nobody knows who [ __ ] peter parker's and
uh
yeah i don't forget where i was going
with that i look forward to the next
movie which is peter parker and vincent
identity
right look peter parker gets his social
security number
parker forges a birth certificate he's
unknown to the world
um all right
all right another good question
all right we got one more to
go okay last question uh
the ryan t show podcast
is uh interested to know
what film did you enjoy the most all
year
little little last minute wreck
uh going into
the end of the year
i mean i'm i'm tempted to say spider-man
because it was such a crowd pleaser
um
but what film did i enjoy the most enjoy
most
hmm
i'll jump in i'll fill some time
um as much as i like spider-man i think
the last
10 minutes of ghostbusters was
the most fulfilling thing i've seen
earlier
i'm entering 20 21 movies to see what
came out
now i'm going to go through every one of
them no
january 10th 2021
feature films released between
1-1
21 and
12 000 titles what the [ __ ]
that seems wrong
yeah let me scroll through and see if
there's anything that leaps to mine
where i was like oh that was my favorite
experience
i think i'm going to watch licorice
pizza tonight i just got the screen of
the new paul thomas anderson movie
yeah i got a bunch of screeners i got to
go through i just got the screen for a
nightmare alley which i did you yeah i'd
watch the [ __ ] out of that
um they uh
the uh i watched the house of gucci
i watched uh
um
uh which macaw the other oscar movie
uh i don't know i've i've seen a few of
the oscar screeners so far
but uh oh i watched the being the
ricardo's
oh yeah yeah it was it was worth
watching they did great like those two
will definitely get nominated i i feel i
feel like
um
hmm
ghostbusters afterlife shang chi those
are two movies i actually saw in a movie
theater
i saw belfast and enjoyed it but you
know some people are like that's going
to win best picture and i i enjoyed it
but i didn't know if it it didn't
necessarily feel like a lock for best
picture
right
um i'm sorry i was kids i'm scrolling
through the movies here to see if
there's anything that makes me go yeah
i got three that i know will probably be
on my top ten okay what do you got
doom
which i really enjoyed especially second
second time around
um in the heights
which i did i i loved
that experience that was one of my first
back in the theater experiences um so i
really dug that one
and summer of soul did you see summer of
seoul the documentary yeah not yet how
is it it's beautiful um it's quest
love's directorial debut
where he apparently somehow discovered
footage for a series of concerts
that took place
in 1969 in harlem it was like the harlem
music festival music and cultural
festival
um that has been lost for like 40 years
and then
like resurrected and so suddenly you get
like slime to family stone and you get
um a bunch of gospel singers i think you
get i can't even remember who else was
on that you get like miriam mchebby you
get a great gospel you get stevie wonder
like all of these um this anina simone
performance is gorgeous
but it is the snapshot of the
sort of counterprogramming to woodstock
which happened the same summer um
but it's this wonderful cultural
artifact
and it's so [ __ ] joyous and it's so
lovely and wonderful
um
that is i think it's on hulu it premiere
not hulu i mean it's 100 worth tracking
down because it's just it's so great if
you like music
you could get nominated for
best documentary but it has a really
strong chance of winning too yeah yeah
for sure
um the eyes of tammy faye i really liked
that'd be high on my list this year
i've watched it twice her performance is
pretty wonderful and and garfield is
really great in it too uh jessica
chastain she both came home
um i'm still scrolling
through movies
god so many did come out
yeah it wasn't like the year before
where we were all locked inside and
nothing came out this is the year that
everything came now
yeah and it's also like this stuff that
um that went streaming first that it's
hard to find on lists to remind me oh i
saw that i remember seeing that oh that
was cool i like suicide squad i enjoyed
the [ __ ] out of that
uh but my favorite
favorite movie of the year i keep
looking through the list kids one's not
leaping to mine instantly and that's not
to say like you know there weren't great
movies but one's not
jumping right into matt i do look
forward to the tragedy of uh macbeth oh
yeah i mean denzel washington doing
[ __ ] shakespeare as directed by a
coen brother like
you know and with francis mcdormand as
lady macbeth i can't imagine not loving
that movie
um so that might take top spot
yeah um
this is unfair but i've seen clerks
three and that was my favorite
it was like it was made for me mark
it's your favorite movie of 2022
and 2021 and 2021.
um ghostbusters was really uh like i
agree with jc the last like [ __ ] you
know half hour of ghostbusters was
incredibly
rewarding emotionally sized everything a
movie is supposed to be and make you
feel and stuff like that
um but i guess we'll come up with our
real lists uh we come back at the in in
2022 i can't imagine we'll do this again
before 2021's over so this probably be
it kids this be it you know what else
was great i remember seeing this when
did i catch this
must have been over the summer
um
mitchell versus the machines
oh that was my uh the guy one of the
guys or both of the guys that did into
the spider-verse right yeah miller and
lord yeah produced it it's on netflix
it's great
it is so great um i can't recommend it
highly enough if you missed it when it
came out like in june or whatever the
hell it was it's worth circling back for
it's a ton of fun
i will look for it man i like those guys
zack snyder's justice league i put that
on my top 10 list this year four hours i
had a good time watching that
it could be two or three slots in your
top ten yeah
mark did a whole podcast on how much he
liked it
it was great
absolutely
um
yeah
a lot of people talking about pig too do
you see obama's list and had pig on it
as well
you know he's he's got a collective case
for a former president
i uh
but i i i didn't bump into anything on
his list i respected it but i was so
glad to see
like like most of us he too is like i
like nick cage
that guy he's got a future you see that
[ __ ] trailer for the new nick cage
movie where he plays the cage the
unbearable weight of massive genius is
that what it's called oh my god it looks
fantastic don't you hate yourself for
not suggesting that movie sooner
nick cage be like hey man you want to do
a movie where you play yourself
yes i do yeah yes i do
kids uh we're a few days away from uh
christmas and uh or the holidays
colloquially or whatever so
uh have a merry one or a happy one
whatever you're gonna have um thank you
of course you can see the
snowflakes falling in our
fat man the on-screen holiday theme here
on
in that sweet
compliments of jc
we enjoy this time that we get to
hang out with you
uh every week mostly every week
um
astrid haven said dude talk about
spiderman and we're out well astrid we
did that you know back at seven o'clock
did we start this show six o'clock six
o'clock just scroll back a bit yeah it's
6 30am i mean we've been on that we've
been doing the show for two hours and 40
minutes now almost so i feel like
wait when did we start yeah we see yeah
we started about 6 20. over two hours we
talked about spider-man a long time ago
this is the end of the show so
go rewind to the top um we thank our
sponsors the good folks that keeps the
good folks at manscaped we thank jc
who's uh taking time away from his uh
family vacay and big bear
to uh to be with us and and make sure
the show is is coming to you all
uh you know we thank the good folks at
marvel who put out a bunch of stuff this
year nine things which
and
quite a controversy with
apparently
um
but not the ranking just that there are
nine and we did all of them crazy but uh
we got to thank uh the guy without whom
there is no show the guy sitting over
there man
uh the guy who uh comes up with better
endings
uh for movies all the time and stuff
like that and just made his own
short film uh i did i just saw a rough
cut did you
i did
and
well it's it's it's rough
but it's there you know i think the
bones are there but we got them we got
to do some massaging we got to get in
there
i'll never forget um seeing the first
rough cut of the first episode of tv
that i wrote and i was despondent
because it was awful
but one of the one of like one of the
show runners that leans over is like
don't worry about it they're all this
bad the first time you see them like
once we get in there once we whittle it
down once we add all the things like
we got it it's all in there don't worry
and so that's sort of how i feel now
which is like it's not awful but it's
just yeah no we're
we're like 40 away
so i feel good
look at that man
look at that guy's a [ __ ] filmmaker
now
so when people like where's your movie
mark mark could be like
here is my movie here it is
um we look forward to doing more of this
with you in uh 2022 kids uh if we can
all survive the omicron wave that's
coming at us um maybe optimus prime
could defend us from the omicron wave
um there are going to be shows comic
book shows galore
this year that i'm going to uh including
one coming up in new orleans in january
yeah if uh if you know they're not
if if
we're not shut down i can't imagine they
shut the world down again though because
we got vaccines right that's the
difference between last time and now
like yes omicron's going around but
people are vaccinated like
yeah i mean i still think that there
will be those events where you just have
to decide for yourself if those are dice
you want to roll
um
you know it's not quite as
it's
the infection rates are high but the
mortality rates are not as high as they
had been
you know but
there may be these smaller events these
smaller conventions even these bigger
ones might just say you know what
we're going to wait broadway's beginning
to slow down again they're canceling
like new year's eve broadcasts like
yeah as we saw last week with snl
yeah went away hey uh december i think
it's december 24th like new year's eve
or christmas eve rather on friday or
whatever
um on roku
that show slugfest that the russo
brothers produced and and um oh yeah
or
it their debut it on roku so you could
watch it the trailers up online
uh now we i try to show it but we'd get
thrown off [ __ ] youtube as per usual
but it is so worth watching and not
because like i narrated it it's just if
you love the world of comic books
particularly dc and marvel
this show is it's you will absolutely
endure this show so i think it starts
airing on roku
on december 24th maybe 22nd through 24th
but it's
look for it it's so worth watching
that's great
but yes uh thank the man over there give
it up for mr mark bernardin ladies and
gentlemen
that is gonna be your uh fat man
beyond
for 2021 kids
we're not going to see you again till
next year
[Music]
um and when we see you again it'll be
some more good times uh we'll have
lots more to chit chat about i would
assume what's what else is coming out oh
[ __ ] star wars so next up
next step
yeah we'll start [ __ ] going down on
boba
which sounds exactly as dirty as i meant
it i know it did
um
there it is kids
have a merry christmas
have a happy holiday
uh just
enjoy life is so [ __ ] short like it
is enjoy find something
happy
yeah be happy and then
finish 2021 in a good mood
um
it's
it's worth it it's worth the effort
um find your happiness where you can
find the kids mine
is right here
talking [ __ ] silly [ __ ]
with you all getting yelled at from time
to time
but
i wouldn't have it any other way man pop
culture
uh brings us all together thanks for
giving uh me something to do
on a wednesday night how's that and
somebody to talk with about you know
[ __ ] all the [ __ ] that i love
so there it is kids for 2021
that is fat man beyond i'm kevin smith i
am mark bernard
tune in in 2022
same
fat time same
fat channel smodcast.com or
youtube.com kevin smith the biggest of
all
jeff's kisses ladies and gentlemen
this is the cat
greetings everybody and welcome to the
aka ask kev anything every saga has a
ten year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
jay and sam bob get old i'm kevin smith
[Music]